the Star Wars Jedi fallen order we've
been waiting so you can like know what
we're talking about Star Wars yeah we've
been waiting so long for details on this
game I can't believe it can you believe
in LA and we're finally here to help us
get things started we've got the head of
respond Vince Zampella and the director
of Star Wars Jedi fallen order Stig as
mucin everybody give it up for Vincent's
day come on
[Applause]
are you doing good give me give me the
hug [ __ ] let's get it going yeah yeah
please keep it co and they're making a
Star Wars game
guys welcome to EA play thank you great
welcome how are you feeling right now no
pressure
your suboxone ounce may be one of the
biggest if not the biggest games of your
lives I know let's dig answer this one
you're supposed to answer this an off
script so yeah we're totally off they
gave me cards that was so awesome to be
here hey play it see three it's Star
Wars yeah and it doesn't really get any
bigger than that yeah this is something
that's Stig and I have been envisioning
for years to see it come to life and be
able to show you guys fifteen minutes of
gameplay today uncut alright alright
so everybody's anxious to see what this
fifteen minutes is going to be yeah for
somebody watching right now who's just a
FIFA fan they don't know anything what
is happening what is this game all about
Vince this is a single-player
action-adventure game set post set post
order 66 after the events in Episode
three what all the Jedi were hunted down
while that on all when the Jedi were
contaminated
so Stig that's the nutshell of the
entire game what are we about to see
where are we at in the game right now
for context okay so Cal's like this
takes place maybe about three hours into
the game okay so Cal's built himself up
he's not a lowly Padawan anymore but
he's not a full Jedi yet sure like Vince
said this is unedited we had one of our
star players Blair this is an expert
playthrough okay so we're gonna see some
really cool stuff he practiced a few
times two or three Blair two or three
point two or three dozen it takes place
on Kashyyyk Milwaukee rookie planning of
course and Cal's on a mission to restart
the Jedi Order and it takes him here to
Kashyyyk and the Wookiees have been
enslaved by the empire was basically
siphoning the planet for all its
resources to build up the imperial war
machine got it alright so I brought up
my phone not to be rude of course it
wouldn't be Greg Miller if I didn't look
at the twitch chat and yeah they are all
through with us talking they'd like to
see the game we've gone on long enough
we're not gonna drown it's two feet
well let's roll you like to kick up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over here
[Music]
[Music]
pure SAP refinery lights dead ahead -
the Empire wall with tree sap another
good the refiners happened to a powerful
compound and they rushed in to expand
production
[Music]
we have to stop them has to play we
don't know they're in game but they
spread themselves to with it this map
we've recovered but these refineries
double as brutal prison camps use those
cutters to create a distraction bug you
take your lightsaber in freedom walkies
inside we need their help to stop the
Empire
understood watch yourself in there you
hear them saying use my help breathe
lovely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over there one of the cutters turned on
[Music]
gonna need to get through here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
think you can help me bTW
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you sure you want to plug into this
thing okay
[Music]
[Music]
this thing
[Music]
just wanted to turn that cutter on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
patrol the base got another breach down
here is some kind of webbing that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I just heard from the captain they're
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
and our reinforcements every good sir
the fewer distractions the better
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll help
[Music]
they just like this
guards
[Music]
for you
[Music]
visitation is not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the little boy guys congratulations that
looks pretty awesome thank you I have a
million questions and I know we're short
on time as always I want to point out
though in the twitch chat Gwyn 96 says
that's freaking cool but he didn't use
fricking um how does it feel - I think
deliver right like and you guys liked it
right I think looking at the twitch chat
there's a lot of people who liked it
like what does that feel like to finally
show this game oh it's great I mean
being involved with this teams you know
Stig and his team have done an amazing
job they put so much of themselves into
this game to be able to be involved in
something like this is just you know
dream come true yeah agreed
huge shout out to the team everybody
everybody who bought said the bots on
the demo but also the whole game the
whole game is coming together right now
so it's amazing feeling I'm just so
proud to be up here and I hope that uh
Star Wars fans understand that we're
really doing our best to try to honor
the brand I mean I think from whatever
you wanna clap from you platform I think
that's pretty evident from it in I like
when we introduce our talking about the
fact that this is a skilled person
playing it right we all see it we think
it looks awesome what are we missing by
not having our hands on the controllers
like what what what is the lightsabers
feel like um it's fantastic like because
it looks like it's got weight to it and
throwing it and catching it right like
that's the impact I think I want from it
absolutely yeah I mean it's it's really
satisfying I'm the game itself it's like
it's thoughtful combat as stig likes to
call it it's it's what you saw was a
really good player yeah right so you
right over there again gave out
autographs after this panel
so you can block parry deflect like we
want the combat to feel really good for
people to go in and be able to like be
part of that and size up the enemies
where when things feel right it's it
feels really good yeah it's it's also
it's about the enemy arrangements as
well like what enemies we're putting you
up against and how you go in and use
your tools yeah take them down but it's
not just lightsabers it's the force as
well sure well that's part of this you
were talking to me last night about it
right this thoughtful combat and the
idea that when I watched the demo
initially my thought was oh these are KN
animations right I'm doing a force grab
and stabbing the guy and that's all I
hit r1 and that happen that's not that
well it's all freeform so like you can
go back in and replay things and do it
differently or absolutely and actually
the enemies react to each other in
different ways you saw the flame
troopers fighting against the spiders
you could says by standard and just kind
of watch that fight if you wanted to
yeah but you're not gonna get any skill
points upon either it's fun to watch
sometimes but it is a lot more fun to
play you talk about the skill points are
those going into the force abilities
yeah so we're gonna have the classic
abilities we're gonna have push-pull
we've got what we call force flip which
is essentially double jump which is nice
because that's something that makes
sense and Star Wars Jedi actually doing
a double jump but we have one unique
expression of the force that you saw in
there which is slow which is a little
bit of the glue between force push and
pull yeah what that was awesome I think
I thought you couldn't top my favorite
moment in the demo right where you come
around the corner grab the stormtrooper
force pull stormtrooper stabbed him but
when you forced all the structure and
walked him in yes that's one of my
favorite might be the first time I saw
that I freaked out a little you actually
said it better be in the demo yeah well
you did it you delivered tell me about
the enemies we are seeing there right
because that's one of those things I
feel like we're talking a lot about
seeing things a lot about is we're
running through the environment you had
different things you had your normal
stormtroopers you had non normal
stormtroopers yeah and this is just a
small portion of the game by the way so
there's a lot more that we have in here
saying that isn't the entire game that
is not no we got we got our classic
stormtroopers we've got the scout
troopers who you saw equipped with kind
of melee charged weapon we've got the
flame troopers but we also have the
purge troopers whose task is basically
hunt Jedi
yeah soften them up before the
inquisitors come in in like we're seeing
right here right like this this bad
exactly like so knew that the team
created the charge Jordan did the
concept good job Jordan so we're going
through and you have these new
stormtroopers you have your fire
troopers you have one of my favorite
droids of all time coming back the K X
and then making me fight him yeah why
would you do that I don't owe you do no
trust me you do I do
yeah yeah well then talk about the other
star of this 15 minute demo right the
new droid bb-8 is right there Thank You
pv1 he's adorable as I'm sure you know I
immediately want him as a backpack so
just a heads up if you're talking to me
in a licensing department that all right
um we can make what is he do in the game
right excuse me we're hosting a man keep
it down over there what are the traits
what are we using as he just Flair is am
I using him for buildings like
story-wise he he's cows companion yeah
explore droid which is perfect his cows
on this mission check for survival
that's taken them to all these savage
planets BT sounds for buddy droid one
which is a that's respawn ended up
sticking yeah one of the cool factoids
is he's his voice is authored by the
legendary Ben Burtt Onis who did all the
sounds sound main sound designer in the
original trilogy and John but you can
hack doors computers as we saw in there
I'm just scanned some stuff there yep
okay environment for like environmental
storytelling learn more lore about the
planet I saw him shooting out health
packs if that a can animation after a
fight is it a button I'm hitting
it's player input okay whenever they
walk down on it whatever they want be
willjack to stimpak okay there's a
limited amount I'll find more over the
course of the game and you're actually
in that moment you're defenseless so you
got to choose wisely when you're gonna
do it okay
um we've talked we've seen the gameplay
without spoiling stuff for me what's
going on in this story like obviously
Cal yeah I thought he was gonna be way
weaker as a Jedi you know just tell me
the whole story what a to be Stig how's
it go . i can't believe i've gone this
long in the panel without asking is
Watteau in this game I can't say tag
Watteau 2019 I'll be retweeting them all
after this panel thank you very much but
let's go through the story outside of
water should be in it
well story is a really big deal deal to
us we've created this with Lucasfilm
it's we got to keep a really tight lip
on it so I can't I don't really want
sorry I mean yeah the story to say it
okay I know one of the things a lot of
people have been asking right I'd put up
stuff on Instagram saying hey give me
questions community wanted to know this
is Star Wars Canon right you slowly can
okay totally legit okay into the real
Cal's of real character yeah saw stopped
saw a girl right there
he's uh you know obviously part of this
Star Wars universe Cyr cows mentor yeah
they're all gonna live in other places
okay that's great
Vince how's that feel no pressure it
feels great yeah yeah I mean we have
[Music]
like I said I'm just like shocked to be
up here I mean like I know it's a big
deal to work with me but it's okay we've
been talking about this for like 10
years yeah
the other big community question I've
seen a lot is it's a Star Wars game in
Star Wars in the past have allowed us to
go light or dark is that a choice here
no okay well why not because no I think
it goes back to the fact that Cal's
authentic yeah and he has to fill a
certain role so we can be used in other
places yeah this is a Jedi story well
that's the thing I appreciate the most
that you guys are coming in and telling
a story right like I think that's why so
many of us are excited for it is the
idea that this is a Star Wars story that
you guys have something to tell
something to say and a lot of walls to
run on Vince's take anything you want to
say to the fans before we let you go
just thanks for the support the the the
energy here is great that's fantastic
fantastic online like everyone's
reaction is fantastic amazing
bowling the team badass thank you guys I
go to your hard work now we just have to
finish can't wait to bring it to you
guys there's so much more that you
haven't seen yet I can't wait to show
you believe it or not there's so much
more there is more at the Microsoft
conference tomorrow that's right
Vince steak thank you so much for coming
out November 15th can't come soon enough
for those of you here at EA play the
respawn team has brought even more
gameplay for you to check out over the
Star Wars Jedi fall in order theater and
for those of you at home extended I was
supposed to do a bit for those of you at
home you will stay tuned for apex
legends yeah you're looking for thank
you for the yeah like that's the
corniest joke I put this thing oh it's
good thanks for watching we got more EA
play for you now
[Applause]
how are we for Star Wars so hype hype
mode engaged although that's actually a
lie it was engaged about three days ago
anyway so big [ __ ] surveys and stick for
sharing that exciting deep dive into
Star Wars Jedi fallen order all a little
bit too excited here not gonna like I'm
Julie Hardy and a little later on adam
freeman and i will be bringing you news
on battlefield 5 yeah right now though
EA play is in full swing with gamers
getting their hands on all kinds of
exclusives there's a lot to look forward
to starting with our next show apex
legends so Alex golden boy Mendes is
bringing you the hottest news on apex
legend season 2 we've got info on a new
weapon new bypass new mode add a reveal
of the 10th legend stay tuned because
apex legends is pirates away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything dies
looking for you
what's going on buddy welcome to EA
plate 2019 and I'm so excited to talk
about apex legends here at EA play I'm
professional eSports commentator Alex
golden boy Mendes now everyone at
respawn has been working diligently and
making apex legends the best battle
royale game out there we've got some big
updates that's right that's right I like
that like that baby bring that energy we
got some exciting details to share on
apex legend season 2 including a brand
new weapon a new mode an improvised or
an excuse me and improvise you hear me
I'm improvising an improved battle pass
a reveal of the 10th legend coming to
the arena and so much more so let's jump
out of this dropship dive right into the
hot zone
take it away Jay thanks golden boy I'm
response community manager Jay Fischetti
as you can see we've brought Kings
Canyon to life right here at EA play
we've even got all nine current legends
here to help me bring you some of the
season 2 updates that you've been
hammering for we're gonna introduce you
to our newest legend after the show but
for those of you at home don't miss your
chance to jump into our legendary hunt
event check it out
beyond is upon us prepare yourself
the legendary hunt has begun legends can
compete to enter an all-new apex elite
cube complete challenges for exclusive
cosmetics I could do this all day
earn XP and battle pass boosts and find
all new exclusive skins in the in-game
store only the strong juvenile and slow
for a limited time legends who place in
the top 5 of any match will earn the
right to join the apex elite cube I need
some help over here
solid copy there they will have the
opportunity to test their skills I need
some ammo against the most talented
legends in the game
additionally legends can complete
legendary hunt challenges to earn
rewards like the epic master of the hunt
bloodhound the wolf pack g7 another game
wah wah and hunt down to wins to score
the exclusive legendary teemed beast
triple take post in the gods and you
shall be rewarded opening fire during
the event all battle pass owners will
receive the free legendary honored pray
our 301 hit level 15 on your battle pass
and you'll also earn the legendary night
terror race you know what I look like
come find me every day legends can also
earn an entire battle past level for
your first top 5 finish of the day thank
you for the fun fight and we're doubling
down with our first ever double xp
weekend one moment from June 7th to June
9th earn double XP on both your base and
battle pass progression throughout the
event be sure to keep an eye on the
rotating store for new exclusive
legendary hunt cosmetics the sky has
opened and gifted the day
I've been droppin as the legendary hunt
won't last forever
good luck legends
let the hunt begin
[Music]
that's right until June 18th you can
jump into of the legendary hunt our
limited time event that features the
debut of our elite Q exclusive
challenges you can unlock and some
killer skins and more also this weekend
is double xp weekend so there's lots of
great reasons to jump in the community
really brought it since this event
launched and it's awesome to see the
best Duke it out back to you golden boy
thank you so much Jake Thank You Jay for
that appreciate it
alright I'll season one who's ready to
talk about season two I like that so you
know I listen i play this game everyday
it's one of my favorites and I did this
like right before the show started
that's how that's how much I play this
game and you know I'm gonna jump back in
when we finish up but first I do want to
talk about season two we've got the
first details here and joining me we got
drew McCoy in the house ladies and
gentlemen drew we've been so patient for
that beautiful beautiful content what do
you have for us today well it's coming
okay
first and foremost content is coming
tonight you've heard of here first so
season two it's coming July 2nd and it's
called battle charge all right
so battle charge will be coming out what
can we expect though in this new season
drops yeah so as we announced when we
launched the game we're taking a
seasonal approach so we're trying to
cram as much into the launch of season 2
as possible with some other stuff along
the way but what you can expect from the
launch is a new legend I do weapon a new
way to play the game okay
perhaps a map event and a lot of this
has been done through a lot of feedback
from community we're also changing up
some of the meta balance of weapons to
try and buff up some of the weaker
weapons and bring a lot of cool stuff in
the game okay all right it's a lot it's
a lot we're gonna talk about a good
portion of it here but let's talk about
that sweet new content because season
two is bringing a new weapon to the
fight and today we're excited to show it
to you so let's just go ahead roll the
clip show it
care package touching down they usually
carry their platforms elves down here I
am taking fire friends hi babies and
applause
[Applause]
your ignorance meets your end
Bonita good job me a new season strong
[ __ ]
Oh ragout
[Music]
we can't make in contact with enemy
[Music]
accept it I'm here you're not there you
have it the old star man I remember
getting slapped by this gun in time
falter though pretty excited to see this
one making it to the fold in the arena
seems really powerful so tell me more
about its place in the entire weapon
loadout for apex legends yeah so the
health stars knew it's coming launch of
season 2 it's actually a care package
weapon because it's so Opie it's just
amazing but it's like the master for the
crater it's it's incredibly powerful
yeah and being a care package weapon it
doesn't use any existing animal on the
ground so whatever you get with it is
what you got I also noticed too it
shattered through doors yeah I can open
bars so like Bailey's grenades and Al
Star Wow okay so that is pretty sizable
now what other changes are gonna be
coming to weapons cuz I and this may
seem very nerdy but I'm a huge fan of
hop-up so I'm all about Prowler with my
well my switch fire that's that's my jam
yeah what are you bringing me yeah so I
can mention there's gonna be some meta
changes to the weapons we're trying to
bring up some of the weaker weapons and
then yeah there are two new hop ups
coming not really gonna say what they
are yet you guys got to wait for season
two but there is a chance that maybe a
me mobile weapon named after an African
country is usable is usable yeah okay
perhaps alright perhaps I mean that is
yet to be seen well that's good if your
reality alright cool so we're sorry not
hot with that l star light machine gun
we also have the battle pass and you
know when you guys first spoke about the
battle paths you said that it was a
learning experience what's different
this time around for season two yeah so
we've been listening to community a lot
Season one didn't quite launch as well
as we were hoping the content was fairly
underwhelming for players so we've been
taking that in we've been getting all
sorts of data from people buying skins
to what they equip on their characters
or weapons and so we've we've we've
taken this learning and put it in a
season to battle pass so first off the
bat it's challenge based now instead of
essentially time-based so you'll get
daily and weekly challenges and they
stack if you don't play for a while so
you can come back after a month
and try and knock them all out on a
weekend at level up really quick
ultimately this doesn't mean levelling
level 100 is a lot quicker than in
season 1 we're also getting rid of all
the badges and strat track that trackers
taking up space throughout the leveling
process and we are inserting three new
entirely new content types
into the battle paths which we will talk
about later and there's a lot more skins
in that and there's gonna be enough
crafting metals by the time you hit
level 100 to craft your very own
legendary of your choosing
alright I like that okay a lot of value
for that battle path yeah that's that
sounds very exciting
alright and now you know we're talking
about apex it's got some pretty sick
skins what skins you have for me today
yeah so like I mentioned I think our
skin game is being ups pretty
significantly you can see that with the
Wraith skin is specifically from the
legendary hunt event but we got four
legendary skins in the battle pass so we
have two character and two weapon so for
caustic he's got the Prince of Darkness
skin and for octane we're doing the Jade
tiger
I think we're yeah I can see there's
Prince of Darkness right there and then
there is a skin for the Spitfire called
the Intimidator and the r3o one is
getting two skins actually there so the
iron rampage at level 100 okay and then
there's a golden version as well oh man
do you see that I look insane that looks
insane alright now another question that
the community is having they're just
dying to have answered new ways to play
elite q was awesome yeah I think it's
like one of the coolest additions for
apex Legends what else yeah so when we
designed apex Legends we really wanted
to have kind of a competitive core to it
this is a game that's meant to be played
over hundreds of hours and mastered
really deep learning experience and so
the elite Q is our first step towards
getting to a higher competitive stage
okay and so season two I'm really really
really stoked to announce we have a
ranked mode coming ranked mo yeah all
right
so rank mode you'll progress through six
tiers if you're good enough you will cap
out if you are garbage tier like myself
yeah don't worry we'll be with division
together yeah you and me
yeah would up would free I think would
three yeah yes it goes from bronze all
the way up to apex predator and it's
using a special matchmaking for each of
the tiers so the higher you get you'll
probably have some longer matchmaking
times but it's because we're trying to
find the best possible match for you and
then throughout the season you'll be
hopefully gaining tiers and then at the
end of the season you'll get rewards
based on where you ended Wow
to show off for the next season ranked
mode come into apex legends yeah it's
gonna be all that's sick
alright alright alright right I am be
honest with you I'm gonna be all up in
that it's gonna be sick I can't wait I
am legitimately concerned as I mentioned
there would be the first wood division
player which isn't even in it or plastic
Division plastics good yeah that's gonna
hurt but dude I thank you so much for
sharing all these details man guys drew
ladies and gentlemen the respawn team
alright now here's the thing I'm a
lifeline Maine just fine you are to
respect that any lifeline Maine's
in-house Wi-Fi mains
alright but I might change from the new
season drops that's right because J give
the people what they want we want to
know who is the 10th legend joining the
arena
what do you have it's my pleasure Golden
Boy well ladies gentlemen the moment has
arrived the 10th Legend joining the apex
legendre's arena is Watson to help us
get to know our latest legend a little
bit better our team put together this
touching illustrated short let's check
it out
my dearest Nathalie as I write this
letter it's the middle of the night in
late summer an hour ago you cracked the
equations necessary to power the force
field
he showed me up tonight my magnificent
daughter and I couldn't be happier or
prouder of that I always knew you were
special but never did I [ __ ] that a
little girl who taught her stuffed an AC
multiplication tables grow up to master
quantum laser mechanics I ever showed
the syndicate that the modified
containment force field will be
operational in a month's time and it's
all thanks to you maybe just a doddering
old fool trying to hold on to mommy bay
a little while longer before he loses
her to adoption but I do see you I see
this strong brilliant wonderful young
woman you've become and I know when the
day comes that I'm no longer with you
you are going to be just fine
the games will be brilliant because you
are brilliant my daughter can and we do
anything she wants in this life because
she is the smartest woman in the
frontier she tend to mocha pour toujours
papa
[Music]
I did it Bubba I hope wherever you are
you're cheering for me ladies and
gentlemen joining the arena and joining
me now we have three gentlemen who
brought her to life Griffin will and Tom
thank you so much for joining us here
Wow so about that I mean Bible comes
from the chat man cuz that was just that
was just that was a fuse right there hit
me rice frightened huh
but Griffin we'll start with you but
you're one of the legend designers and
I'm curious on the approach that you
guys took toward making Watson a
character that has impact in the arena
so Watson really started as a
conversation between a friend of mine
and I who he's an engineer and he has
this really methodical interesting way
of taking really complex problems and
systematically solving them and so I
kind of thought what would it be like if
we took the sort of the defensive
complexity of Apex and introduced a
character that could really create a an
ecosystem in which you can survive the
really aggressive third party meta all
that stuff so the the idea behind Watson
really is that if you if you plan and
you sort of adapt to the environment you
really know the map and you work closely
with your team that you can really
create these strong defenses that that
people are gonna really have to think
about in terms of how yeah they push on
you and that sort of thing so that the
current meta of I hear gunfire and I hit
it as hard as I can you know with
Bangalore Wraith octane all of those
we're trying to sort of bump that meta a
little bit and make it so that this this
more stance
RTS kind of play style has breathing
breathing room yeah yeah try to provide
like options for the players yes yeah I
want to be able to play that hyper
aggressive approach whether you're
running like a composition that contains
like a typical one which would be like a
Pathfinder Wraith and a lifeline for
that support yeah you can you can play
in the accomplish
like this they kind of counter yeah one
another so that that's that's gonna be
really fun we're gonna dive into the
abilities and everything that she does
because let me tell you it's insane now
as far as the look and feel my favorite
part about apex let apex Legends is that
the characters the legends themselves
they stand out when you're looking from
far away you see the silhouette and you
know exactly who it is that you're about
to engage with what were some of the
complexities in bringing a character
like Watson to life yeah so it's a
collaborative effort you know got out
Heath and Sam animation Department
everybody kind of works together we were
given a specific set of skills that she
would be using abilities from Gryphon
and that's kind of all we had to go off
of so we had to heat that a great job of
like bringing it all together giving her
a sort of a grounded aesthetic using she
had to look like she was using
electricity and stuff like that so with
rubber gloves and the coils and the
wires and pushing her silhouette at the
same time making her style you have to
be able to read who she is from
different distances from there from
there you can really go in and sculpt
all the details out and work with the
animators to really bring her life give
her personality in everything that she
does with her abilities and that - yeah
and there's some really cool stuff there
as well every every part that Watson she
takes out an item in her kit it's
actually like on her person oh yeah you
see it happen yeah and those are all
very meticulously designed by the
concept artist and then and then modeled
out in 3d so yeah it's all functional
that's great in the world yeah so now
you get to the to the gameplay the look
but the story you know because you got
to hit us in the fields right like super
hard and you just did that
Watson's backstory who she is let's
let's dive deeper that what some kind of
different from the way we usually do
things because usually that's very
collaborative and we're creating the
character at the same time all the
different departments and we're working
together
Watson was different she was already
designed and and drawn when I got her
and one of the great things about
working at respawn is is they they
encouraged us to create characters that
are
traditional and there are characters you
haven't seen in video games before and
to kind of branch out and see what else
you know what other people have the
people can we represent out there and so
Watson is a very different character
than I've ever seen in a video game at
least and everything is based off of
what these guys created I mean it's all
every single part of her backstory is
connected somehow to either her
abilities or her look and now something
that kind of stuck out to me so am I
correct in assuming that Watson played a
big role in the arena itself yes so
Watson and her father actually invented
the ring okay and so she grew up in the
arena literally in the arena when they
were building it and we're gonna start
to you're gonna see with Watson and
moving forward we're gonna start to
build the lore of this world a little
bit you're gonna find out who created
the games they mentioned the syndicate
in there so we'll talk about the
syndicate down the road your build more
and more of a universe yeah which is
great so she's in eure so all the
legends must know her oh yeah she was
their kid sister basically she was
always hanging around the arena and I
she got to know all the legends and got
to watch all of them she's not a
mercenary she's not a soldier
you know she her roles of support and so
she everybody loves Watson she's the one
person that could probably unite all the
legends together cluding caustic caustic
respect sir she's a scientist okay she's
an engineer okay I like when he's wrong
word for copy yeah I don't know if
constable likes anybody okay that's
that's fair well yeah that's cool I mean
blown away by this character so far now
I mentioned before we're gonna talk
about the abilities because when you
reveal these to me I was floored
jaw-dropping in a lot of people online
were kind of like guessing mm-hmm as to
like what it would be and I'm very happy
to see that a lot of them some some had
the right idea but for the most part
what she's capable of doing is
ridiculous so let's talk about the
active first thing defense is yes so the
the Watson has more interrelated
abilities than probably any other
current character we have you really
need to understand how they all interact
the fences you can place 12 nodes and
you can use these in any permutation you
want part of why we
I sort of went was that her being such a
brilliant electrical engineers because
we really want to reinforce both
mechanically and thematically how
creative the player can be with these
basically we're just giving you free
rein to place these however you want and
figure out and the players they like I
just saw right there don't know if that
was intentional this other when your
teammates go through it's yeah it's off
so I'm downed and they run through the
gate there's the gate deactivate yes oh
so there's a lot of different
interactions a lot of different ways
that you can interact with the gates
with other characters the ultimate is we
call it an interception pylon that
shoots down bombardments incoming
grenades stop Sark star spam and it
charges your team shield and also if
Watson's cooldown is slower when she's
away from the pylon but when you're near
the pylon it supercharges your your
tactical so you get fences faster so if
you drop it down it's uh it's a it's a
permanent structure until it's destroyed
and that allows you to build these large
fortresses very rapidly you can use that
for defending for flank control on
offensive squads for going up on a tower
and fencing it off the Pathfinder and
then the passive is that ultimate
accelerants give you your ultimate 100%
ultimate charge and so if you save up
ultimate accelerants over the course of
the match that allows you to place more
pylons and it means that you don't have
to play conservatively as watson as long
as you save up ultimate charges you can
keep moving with this with a highly
mobile squad you can play offense
defense support however you feel like
the fences and the pylon are most
effective to whatever comp your plan oh
you're telling me here is that lifeline
mains do not need to continuously hold
ultimate accelerants anymore we that was
that was we felt like we needed to
that's right we did it people finally
cuz everyone's like really mean to me if
I don't like use the old takes out it's
not fair oh wow so that is that is that
is ridiculous they cross the fences you
get pinged as well yeah so if any
enemies cross through the pense defenses
it pings your entire squad so there's a
situational awareness element to them as
well wow if you know this is why I like
she grew up in the arena if you know
we're all that took points the exits are
you can set up
census there and you'll know exactly
when it enemy yes I'm even thinking
about like compositions and how like it
could work out you know maybe for any
Gibraltar mains out there maybe you find
a little no one cheered for that feel
sad man maybe there's like a little
little synergy there that King King
created there's a lot that can be done
with these fences and being able to
block off certain chokes yeah
it's I think it's really the big sort of
the ceiling is how creative people can
get with it and I'm really excited to
see what people do with it and and from
the from an art perspective here you
know they're very distinct they stand
out what were some of the challenges in
making sure that these fences really
like when a player saw them they knew
they knew exactly what it was not to
kind of catch them off guard so to speak
to make it really really stand out in
the arena yeah again silhouettes
everything you got to make it stand out
and it has to look like it lives in the
world that she's something it's
something that she can use and that
lives on her body as well she's able to
pull it out and she's able to bring it
out and you know create a create a
fortress basically and it has to read so
we had concept artists working on every
little detail and the modelers as well
and we had to test it out we had we
tested out we play it in game or in
house and make sure it reads well these
guys do a tremendous job on the gym like
I need like a post with electricity like
it was between the two yeah and they
just they create really cool stuff with
just that kind of vague hand-wavy
yeah their description about it it's
clearly been thought out this this this
legend is gonna be incredible I can't
wait to play watts you guys excited
Watson that is nutty all right well
again very much looking for right now
today we've covered a bunch here we've
seen a new weapon we've gotten a new
mode the latest legend and the new
battle pass for season two so let's
recap all the amazing apex Legends
action that we've seen here today
surprise
[Music]
like
your time was in
[Music]
I'm not gonna let you off that easy true
what was that what was what what what
was that you saw the giant thing on the
screen in the eyeball what was that
carat weight tell me well let's just say
that well no but let's just say this
we've got a perhaps a couple of big
things coming in to king's canyon and
start a season two okay so keep your
eyes peeled over the next month see what
you can find out so if I were to like
ask you you know after we're done with
this are you like gonna give me the cold
shoulder are you actually gonna tell me
there's no way I can tell you sorry so
man I'm holding elves all the way out
here man this is not it's not fair well
true thank you so much Frank guys apex
legend sees it to July 2nd could not get
here soon enough now if you're in Los
Angeles come check out apex legends at
EA play for your first chance to get
hands-on with Watson as well as all the
other great apex legends things
happening here and for those of you at
home double xp weekend is going on right
now so jump it to the legendary Hunt
event and start earning those amazing
exclusive skins I'm golden boy it's been
a blast
talking apex legends with you all here
today and I'll see you in the arena
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right you just saw a ton of new
info on apex legends season 2 including
a new battle pass first details on
ranked mode and the official reveal of
the newest legend Watsons I'm Greg
Miller here at EA play where gamers are
getting a chance to test drive the
newest legend right now stick around
because up next we've got Julia Hardy
and Adam Freeman giving us the dirty
details on battlefield 5 including looks
at a ton of new maps exciting updates
and details on a new theater of war
all--that's moments away so keep it
locked
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey guys hey welcome to the battlefield
5 show live from EA play in Hollywood
let's hear it
I'm Gianni and today we've got a ton of
new info on some of the great updates
coming to Bao feel 5 in 2019 but don't
just take my word for it my co-host he
reads all of your tweets and I do
actually mean all of them it's a little
bit creepy and weird battlefield
community manager Adam Freeman what have
you got for us Freeman now I may be a
member of the battlefield team but as
you know I'm a fan I know you guys fan -
and you're gonna love what we've got to
you today so over the next half hour
we're gonna be bringing you content
that's coming to you over the next units
we've heard what you want
so today you're getting your first look
at a ton of multi new new multiplayer
maps features we know you've been
screaming out for and the arrival of a
new theater of war that's coming to
Battlefield 5 is 4 so when chapter 4 to
find the odds drops it's bringing so
much cool stuff so let's get to it over
to you Julia thanks Adam that's right
let's wait no longer and tear the
plastic of our first new map
marita let's check it out
the Battle of Greece continues on the
Morita map allied forces are making a
last stand to hold the Axis army
sweeping through the region
[Music]
[Music]
you'll deploy on a sloping Mountain
Ridge and within the tight streets of a
rural town
if the allies control the town but axis
troops are already on its fringes
the road down into the village is
crucial and you must fight to hold here
or risk losing control of the region
you'll always have tactical choices
nearby with a close proximity to other
key locations so keep an eye out for
them marita is an infantry focused map
where all four soldier classes will be
able to shine tanks and aircraft will
stand aside for intense infantry
gunfights and sneaky flanks in the
cobbled streets
Hills and multi-story homes means unique
vertical gameplay stay alert in this
steep environment as the Battle of
Greece rages on
[Music]
to help give us even more details on
Marita
please welcome Ryan McArthur from DICE
yeah so thanks for coming out Ryan
so obviously Marita looks amazing what
was the Maps inspiration well I think
that you know the team in in in LA that
put this together and they built the the
mercury map that everyone saw earlier
this month and so they really wanted to
continue that story of the bottle of
Greece which is a bit of an unknown
story new to me as well
as you as you learn about this stuff so
it's really cool it's sort of set on the
Albanian Greece border sort of in the
mountains there were the the access
power sorta started to push into Greece
during the war and it sort of set above
the clouds and this nice little quiet
well I guess what used to be quiet
village before these guys all show up
and it's a quite a different experience
than mercury in a sort of a totally
different style the gameplay that you
would have seen in the game before so
what kind of gameplay are we talking
about what's happening well so this is
gonna be a heavily infinite infantry
focused map so as mr. battlefield likes
to put it this is total creative chaos
so you're just gonna see some creative
chaos yeah so what we get there was just
head-on just collisions in the middle of
this map and it's it's sort of a what we
tried to do with all the new maps that
we've been created spending a lot of
time to figure out how do we make each
one of them different so when players go
in and play one of these new maps it has
a different feel than the ones they
played before to sort of create that
different experience for them so this
one has I guess for lack of better way
of put it in sort of a banana shape to
it and that banana well I think fruits
important when you're doing game design
I think obviously and so the shape gives
you sort of a variety of different play
styles and sort of creates this sort of
narrow channels for people to just run
head-on into each other which really
creates that that chaos that is
battlefield but it's we won't though
that's what we want that kind of chaos
but most importantly we need to know
like we could talk all days but when we
get our hands on it that's what we want
to know right
yeah I think the great thing for this
this is coming in July as part of
chapter four so stay stay tuned I think
some people are gonna get to play it
while they're here today lucky you all
right Freeman who's we've stuck up there
for no other reason than well my own
entertainment has more on chapter four
view over to Freeman I'm up here PT fo
you given out to me Julia listen we have
more maps so let's deliver a brand new
one to you
this is Alison dan is coming in Chapter
four the fight moves to the North
African desert in a vast new map for
battlefield 5 al Sun Dan prepare to
engage alongside a lush desert coast and
contrasting harsh environments Axis
forces have militarized the area with
camps a radar tower and an airbase you
must fight over possession of these
critical points in al Sun Dan we've
taken the Vista used in a single-player
war story under no flag and double down
on air and land vehicle combat with this
the location has been optimized for
all-out multiplayer action on this open
map is up to you to shape the fight with
large distances vehicle based team plane
and battles across ranges you'll always
have plenty of choices make good use of
this sandbox to secure the win utilize
vehicles mounted guns planes and
transports capture the strategic
airfield to dominate the sky or engage
in fast-paced infantry battles in tight
interior areas al Sun Dan is classic
battlefield
we can't wait to let you play it
yeah that's amazing so what's the owl
sundown was adapted from an to know flag
so tell us a little bit about what that
process was like yeah so usually you
know when the guys say that when the
team sort of focused on building these
war stories they want to create these
nice narrative linear experiences and
sort of that really tell the story of
World War two but with with under no fly
they sort of took a little bit of a
different approach to this and sort of
made this big wide open experience and
and that showed a lot of potential from
a multiplayer perspective as well so
when we finished the game originally the
team wanted to sort of sit down and and
and sort of a small group of them and
take a shot at turning this into what
could be an amazing battlefield it's you
dig map this is your sort of classic
battlefield sandbox up this is where
you're gonna see you know tanks and
planes and infantry and all of that
together in sort of what is what is
truly battlefield it's sort of built for
that open-world gameplay with you know
depending on no matter how you want to
play there's something there for you
yeah oh definitely mm so how the car it
kind of yeah just my strategy because
it's such a wide map like what am i
doing well I think if you look at it
this room for all the from play style so
there's six flags on this one you're
playing conquest and you can see here
even if you see from the videos here
you've got you know when you go into the
village it's all about infantry play and
speed and flanking through the things
and the bridge in the middle it's all
about you know sort of controlling that
with infantry gameplay and I think mr.
battle for the other day decided to just
sit there with his tank destroy me but
that's just something that he likes to
do he's kind of mean but I mean again we
could go on and on over its height four
times there's so much to get to you've
got so many announcements when can we
get our hands on else on that but so
this is the first map that we're gonna
come in with chapter 4 so June 27th this
is gonna be available day 1 chapter 4
for everybody nice nice now we've got a
couple more surprises to come but before
we get into all that let's take a look
at what's coming in August towards the
end of chapter 4
get up close and personal with Chapter
four defying the odds new and intense
close quarter maps are coming to
Battlefield five
by popular demand we're bringing more
maps to players craving tighter types of
multiplayer specially tailored for
intimate infantry combat the new
battlefields will challenge your squad
in unique ways teamwork skill and
adaptation are your keys to victory
[Music]
fight through an explosives production
facility in lieu for 10 islands and
unseat the axis occupation in Provence
prepare to assemble your team and rise
above your enemies and prepare to learn
more about these new battlefields later
in the year
[Music]
now to help us break down these new maps
ride and I are joined by mr. battlefield
himself last Gustafsson because he asked
nicely we also let Freeman point out
from his weird way worse than my
firestorm teammates just leave me behind
everywhere understand why that happens
do you want to take over this one last
these are very different than so the two
maps you've already shown so far today
tell us about Dr I mean taking a step
back we've been closely monitoring how
players engage in tides of war and and
no surprise something they love the
bigger modes like conquest it's always
been kind of a battlefield pillar but
it's been super fun to watch how they
engaged with passion and dedication in
the small amounts like squad conquest
for example which really became a
success and with that in mind and we've
to get it with the dice LA studio
they've been going at it
tailoring maps that are specially made
for small amounts and there's such being
able to give that you know the
close-quarter feeling they're tight what
do you say the intimate combat we're
making when we get back like key
strategies that when you're playing but
you know as we see with these smaller
game modes I mean the key to this is
just really good team play a really good
squad play and so you know sticking
together and not leaving anybody behind
like mr. Freeman over here acceptable
because I would it's too beautiful as
you saw Lofoten it's serenity beautiful
nor the countryside but then kind of
ripped open where the jump fire and
everything amongst villas and and
factory equipment and then Provence
you know I plan to take my wife there
you know let's dance on the square
beautiful couples you know lots of good
flanking your routes and it's the
smaller Maps really allows you to to
master every inch of it it's really
about you know knowing your battlefield
I mean
again we could go on and on so about all
of these that's but we've got one more
map to show off and I want to make sure
we have time to get through it but first
at last you've brought with them some
news about some kind of core gameplay
updates we know that you've all been
waiting for so you're excited about this
one last you know how much time I'm
spending online like I mean I'm working
that's not delve big community features
we're going out this month increase the
max rank private games
let's talk max rank talk max rank we do
know and it's been loudly made to us or
a kind of awareness that there are
players out there too skilled who maxed
out on rank 50 too quickly so we've
taken that to heart and we now taken the
max rank from 50 to 500 so it's quite a
leap and it's moving forward and it's a
grind train but what are people getting
if they're on it yeah we're all in it
you know we want the goodies so to start
with already from rank 51
yeah you will be granted the company
coins for every rank up but then at
every to call them milestone ranks you
know every 50th rank you will get one
shiny new rank icon to show off your
skills and also beautiful set of dog
tags so lots of ways of showing off your
master you you own your journey towards
you know that the world domination it's
the time so it's almost here but with
you it's a world domination for large
bio about world domination when that
what's happening
private games then the other massive
thing that we know players one we got I
mean another one that for lovely
community have been vocal about and
previously for those who haven't been
with battlefield live what's called
Laurie speed they're rented survey
program but now we're shifting over to
private games and what it means the
beautiful thing with it is the baseline
package that come house is free for
everyone that plays battlefield 5 so a
beautiful package it's start to let you
set up your servers and and kind of
create your experiences whether you want
to capture or you know play with your
friends and Freeman you can play with us
which
or thanks you can sit with them and
obviously you know you love getting all
that community feedback so hit him up
mister battlefield at aol.com let him
know that is the thing though like we're
not finished when we're done right no
exactly it's coming in let's see that
term September member yeah and at that
time I mean we want you to dive on it
set up your servers play it and give us
feedback since this is kind of just the
beginning of the journey where the
private games we want to hear what did
we do right and where should we shape up
and and and take it an extra notch so ok
well then don't tell Ryan but you know
you're my favorite for this thank you
very much for it
we've got more than Julia we're done
fighting up here
well let's promise we've got one more
battlefield map to show you it's called
operation underground lars ryan talk us
through what we're about to see yes
let's do a look well this is the the
ultimate definition of a passion project
so Inga you're on the the the original
designer for an operation Metro when we
finished battlefield five and shipped it
he wanted to do something that he just
just was truly invested in so we kind of
went down and he sat down and he came
back with what was operation underground
and when he showed it to the team we
knew we just had to make this and I
think Lars is sort of being part of that
that journey in the beginning I mean you
know how much this meant to the team
yeah I mean I was there when when we
started to build the maps for
battlefield 3 and early on it was kind
of a brainstorm I still remember it was
tons of images on the world we
challenged the team to you know where do
you want to fight everything from subway
to shopping mall to dad knows everywhere
yeah and then the team started or
someone smart not me apparently I only
get to pick one yeah so they started to
pick a number of them and I think Inga
then chose three of them which was the
part the subway and come to the bank
area in the city I mean you don't want
one meal you want three lots of meals
right yeah so you can see when you see
kind of it spinning in brown-nose here
you can see the true inspiration but
what in your run and the talented crew
with him has done is to to kind of take
it hard too
back from the original metro and started
to provide especially a lot of flanking
routes so that you can kind of move
around and be smart about it and tons of
I mean I think as you look at it like
this is this is not Metro remastered
this is as the guys look at it sort of
reimagine and I think you've got a bunch
of different diverse areas you've got
big open courtyards you know it's street
level and narrow streets and you go down
into where you see in the in the video
here with the where the subway cars are
and into the sub basements and you're
gonna find a whole bunch of different
things in different ways to play in
different styles and I know that guys
have a few surprises in there as well
that but I think the community's really
gonna enjoy when they get there so when
when do we get it question five this is
the one the team is really excited about
as well I know I can't wait for October
okay so I have a crack in time played in
play test I'm so looking forward for
everyone else getting to play it too and
everything else that's on these new maps
oh yeah those oh sorry those are the
only surprise is this is the problem
we've got too much to get so just like
stop talking we got so many surprises
view I say today we're giving you
never-before-seen details on battlefield
fives chapter five here's a little look
at what the team's been working on
a timeless theater of war a new vision
prepare to deploy to the Pacific the
team of dice are hard at work creating
an iconic World War 2 experience
releasing this fall with chapter 5 of
battlefield 5 as the u.s. and Japan
enter the fight your clash across
several battlefields including a modern
take on an absolute classic
Iwo Jima since battlefield began the
Pacific Theater has been part of its DNA
now we're crafting the ultimate
reimagining of the conflict by capturing
real-life environments and using the
power of frostbite we're bringing you
the Pacific realized with today's
capabilities and technology take part in
the u.s. invasions as they're
unstoppable forces charged inland
towards unwavering Japanese defenses use
new amphibious units to pummel the war
ridden shores and an expanded arsenal to
bring your squad to victory
we have a lot more to share about the
Pacific and how it will evolve
battlefield 5 later in the year
stay tuned ok most importantly you went
on like a bunch of like research trips
like let's find out more about that
let's set that one in Tahiti yeah that's
right it's amazing how many people are
willing to make that extra effort to go
to Hawaii dan you were in Stockholm yeah
so it's quite quite impressive we really
appreciate the team putting in that work
yeah but obviously I mean this is the
big new the big new addition to
battlefield 5 so going back new through
to war in the Pacific I mean this is
this is a homecoming for Lars I mean not
even team itself but this jokes aside
it's you know having been with
battlefield Oh Ferdy journey it's really
where it all started back in 1942
you know the Pacific Theater and already
when we started to talk about this game
the journey through the Second World War
everyone came up and kind of when drew
go to the Pacific so this is the time it
feels like a homecoming 1942 but if in
1943 we've been there before but this is
in a new way and I think I think the
great thing I mean we hear a lot from
the community and I know you know we
have these discussions you've got where
my US forces where's my Japanese army
and you know can you sit here in LA
today and tell everybody that it's come
in Chapter five you're gonna get those
things you're gonna see some familiar
places like Iwo Jima we've got two other
maps coming with out so three maps
coming with the initial package of the
Pacific and Chapter five
someone's I think that I think people
are gonna be really happy with what
they're gonna see and I just say it's
something that you can hear from the
ping and the in the trailer hang some
iconic things as well Mike and it's
coming right we're living for the ping
so we wouldn't go to Iwo Jima without
kind of the weaponry and the hardware so
bringing tons of iconic weapons gadgets
and also after all it's battlefields so
of course there will be a new set of
vehicles and and we want to take that
extra strap and kind of start giving you
the boats fulfilling that sandbox of
land air and sea and the team has
focused hard
on capturing kind of that invasion
experience I mean it was very much about
island hopping during the war so
capturing deviation experience and the
amphibious warfare so there's tons of
new stuff and a new gameplay to look
forward to and beautiful locations
destroy thank you both very much for
joining us so you've lost track of all
of these brand new battlefield
announcements I don't blame you because
honestly there was quite a lot so I do
you want to give us a little bit of a
recap there shreemant i'll leave that on
your capable shoulders come back of the
balcony fo yeah come on go out there
okay okay we've got a load more
multiplayer maps then coming in 2019
that starts with Alice and Dan on June
27 followed by Marita in July we'll
bring in a brand new fierce report about
four five the Pacific that's releasing
this fall but also bringing features
we've heard the community asks for an
increase in max rank from 50 to 500 and
private games also one final
announcement starting today you can play
battlefield 5 in the EA and origin
access vault and through EA access on
PlayStation 4 when it launches next
month it's not everything much covers it
I guess it won't be stay down here with
them on the adults table or whatever
field show yeah I'm Julie Hardy and I'm
Freeman and if you're in the Los Angeles
area be sure to cover visit us in person
at a play goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so many new maps updates and a new
theater of war I guess that's also if
they're going on vacation with everybody
that's what they're that's what I call
battlefield show everybody for those of
you just tuning in I'm Greg Miller
apparently people don't like me on
Twitter and I'm coming to you live from
EA play where fans are getting hands on
with some amazing new content if you're
in LA and you're not at EA play what are
you doing
III starts tomorrow you have nothing to
do today it's free just come on by it's
great for the rest of you make sure you
keep it here because real soon we've got
Alex Golden Boy Mendes breaking down
FIFA 20 but right now we're shifting
gears to another dice game this one from
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
that's right we're about to talk Star
Wars Battlefront 2 in here to give us an
exciting update from the Star Wars
Battlefront team is Dennis Randall
Dennis how you doing hello there here's
what I need you to do give me the
Battlefront journey from last EA played
here you guys have learned a lot sure
yeah so last year we announced that
we'll be going into the Clone Wars yeah
and then we delivered the new planet of
Geonosis where the Clone Wars sort of
started sure we deliver a bunch of new
prequel heroes and villains that our
players really enjoyed and then finally
we wrapped it up with delivering a new
way to play PvP with capital supremacy
it's a mode where you capture command
posts and take out capital ships and our
community is really happy it's growing
every month that's what you're telling
me yesterday we're doing rehearsals
right is the fact that the community is
getting bigger right they're responding
to the changes in you're listening to
them yeah yeah no this is the perfect
time to join it's you know like our
subreddit is full of love and it's just
a joy to be working for them so you've
already announced some new stuff this
week what is it yes so yesterday we
announced to the core community that
we'll be delivering for this month
capital supremacy is coming to the
planet of Naboo the city of feed so
urban combat is finally getting to be
experienced in that mode and we're also
introducing two new reinforcements the
separatist droid akka which we've been
teasing for a long while so happy to
finally have that one coming and to
combat that for the Republic we're
introducing a new vehicle the tx1
30 tank to finally bring the fight to
the separatist alliance right sure you
also know some new skins what are those
yeah so new appearances are coming a
couple of new clone battalions and
headlined by the general Skywalker
appearance for Anakin
the famous outfit that he wore during
the early day for the Clone Wars in the
TV show in that's my thing Dennis you
talk about lastier but it's starting to
bring in more Clone Wars stuff right now
that you're in a year later no more
clothes why do you think people have
such an attachment to Clone Wars um part
of it is nostalgia like we all grew up
watching it and but I think it's also
because how the TV show really is
enhanced and and continue to explore
more lore and and you let the
personalities of the prequel heroes and
characters really shine okay
what to you is the future of Star Wars
Battlefront 2 so we also announced that
the next planet that we're going to it's
another Clone Wars planet it's alien
planet of Seleucia and we're bringing
that to life in the Frostbite engine
it's going to look pretty fantastic and
we also if that planet will be
supportive of capital supremacy and new
ways to play the game in particular if
you want the epic Star Wars battles of
battlefront but more tailored towards
the PvE experience so and then again
this nostalgia it's nice Clone Wars
great we grew up on it what about the
new hotness are you bringing any of the
new trilogy stuff are we going anywhere
and what's happening tell me just spoil
it right here EA play 2019 so we
considered battlefront to be the
greatest hits of Star Wars where you get
to play the most iconic heroes and
villains and characters from all the
Star Wars films and we'll be back in
August to talk more about if you know
this is EA play right now if you doesn't
to talk about right now turn I can punch
in zoom or something all right Thank You
Dennis thank you now it's time to talk
about competition of a different kind
ladies and gentlemen are you enjoying a
play everyone here well it wouldn't be
EA play if we didn't get into a few
different things Alex Goldman Boyd
Mendes is gonna be hitting the football
pitch with FIFA 20 and we'll be digging
into that reveal trailer that dropped
this morning with some very special
guests that will tell you more about the
newest way to play fifa Volta football
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on fever fans I'm golden
boy coming it to you alive from the
Volta pitch here at EA play now I had a
blast actually hosting a FIFA Ultimate
Team Champions Cup a few weeks back but
that was FIFA 19 today we're here to
talk about FIFA 20 now if you caught the
brand new trailer that dropped this
morning you already know that volta
football is a new way to play returning
football to the street FIFA to the
streets you like that all right now for
those of you who missed it let's take a
look give me a pass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now in a bit I'm gonna be chatting with
Sam Rivera the lead producer at FIFA 20
about some of the new gameplay features
that are gonna be coming to FIFA 20 but
first we go across the pond last week
singer/songwriter and Fulham footballer
Chelsea Grimes caught up with some
special guests to give us the details on
volta football and the culture that
inspired it check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
we've altered producer Jeff ensuite and
Manchester United on England legend Rio
Ferdinand to talk about a subject close
to my heart
street football
[Music]
okay sir Rio we're here in London
your hometown kpop wall street football
what was your like memories and
experiences growing off did you play a
lot of it no this is where I grew up
this is exactly what I've done day in
day out in there The Fool never goes out
of play physically it's demanding you're
forced to almost have a personality and
show personality in there do I mean you
can't hide in there
so I used to play in the street with all
the boys and it was kind of the saying
you know we plan out to bounce it off
heaven and I use the walls on people's
houses there's another player
what was it for you that made you want
to bring it even into the game for us
it's a return to speed football for the
FIFA franchise and we're really excited
about being able to you know be in
places like this you know where it's
rooted in the real people the real place
is authenticity creativity culture are
all things I wanted to bring to - volta
it's amazing that's what you can do in
both of those so that's part of that's
part of the detail in the gameplay so
you can do that my tricks are this well
just being able to be really skillful
with the ball of your feet you know
whether it's a classic futsal drag or
being able to play it off the wall to
yourself to beat your opponent or flick
it up over your head to create space for
an on goal can you use the platform like
the professional savings absolutely so
obviously with it being FIFA we want to
make sure that authenticity is at the
forefront and so you can play with or
against the real players all the license
players that we have all the laces pubs
you can imagine playing Chelsea versus
Spurs in this London Cage
vs Liverpool
[Music]
she's a physical one technically as much
I played on loads of different places
where is it to play on the game so
obviously with Volta it's it's the
world's game and there's so many
locations you can play with from a
rooftop in Tokyo to a London cage like
this or even an underpass in Amsterdam
so you know we want to make sure that
what we're building is you know real to
the space the realest of the people was
there like craziest place you play
football I was actually in a camp in LA
and I played a bit of a bit of soccer
there which as soccer I've never played
that there before and the pitches are a
lot nicer than when I go play maybe in a
favela in Brazil I went to the World Cup
in Brazil my first one I didn't as a
pundit I managed to graduate of
revellers and I look crazy room and
amongst that was just like a pitch in
the middle of it in a cage a bit like
here but just different setting what
type of football were you playing
we played whoever was there so you just
play with the numbers you've got if
there's free be free fine if it was far
besides not a problem so what's great is
that supporter being able to play 3v3
4455 playing with goalkeepers playing
without goalkeepers and you know playing
in a cage like this or playing futsal
you know with more authentic rules
I think Alta does a really good job of
representing the diversity of the game
not only the people but also in the game
style you can feet the wall like your
teammate passing to yourself or you can
be really skillful with the ball like
you know like these guys are being
[Music]
Volta football is such a diverse game
and familiars of people around the world
streets is their stadium so for you guys
like what are some of the fundamental
things that you take away from the
streets what translates to the stadium's
small-sided games freeze free versus
free farm asides I grew up in this
environment I think it enables you
definitely to be able to deal with
people 1v1 because in a game of the
stadium in front of thousands of fans
theme you're gonna have to deal with
someone wanna be one like this with
bigger spaces so you getting used to
that in this type of environment is I
think for a young player it's key having
a personality not being afraid to try
something new yeah and obviously you
know eventually you can go and put it
onto the big stage so I think this is
like yeah you go and express yourself I
think definitely the word that keyword
express if you can express yourself you
see the best in everyone thing
individually as a team you know street
football is for a lot of people words
foundational when it translates to you
know the stadium's for volta that's
that's kind of how we've built the
gameplay experience and so we're really
excited about what we can you know
represent and being able to represent
the the Flair and the in the style that
you guys just talked about I think a lot
of people is well used to always
associate that skills and flair without
the end product I think that's what's
great about this game is it and products
always King
[Music]
my granny when you really want to know
is can you create female players
absolutely I think that's one of the
biggest innovations you can play male or
female and they play with each other as
well and that's an important part of
what we're building when you got
implanted in the live one turns up in a
pair shorts boots come we have like
jeans upper cut downs like I've got or
you can have you know t-shirts and
shorts so you can have jeans and long
sleeves again a big thing for us is you
know being able to establish the culture
that is street football through clothing
through how you look at your personal
style you can have short hair long hair
you can have tattoos no tattoos you can
play with trainers a lot of the time as
well as like it's not least you want to
look good you want to feel good play
good in some of its superstition like
it's all of that all in one if you can
get that into a game and transfer that
and translate that into into the cage
you got it made
that's a big part of bottle football
just being able to represent the people
as they are you know want it to be
authentic want to be diverse you know we
want it to be cultural and creative and
a lot of that is you know how you equip
yourself and how you carry yourself and
how you represent yourself in the game
Jeff thank you so much Rio it's been a
pleasure I can't wait to play Volta so
I'll see it in the cage well there you
have it
Volta football pretty cool stuff there
now I can't wait to get my hands on it
later this summer but to talk to us
about the exciting new gameplay updates
and innovations that are gonna be coming
5420 we have FIFA lead gameplay producer
Sam Rivera here standing by Sam welcome
thanks Alex is great thank you thank you
yeah all right all right
pleasure to have here my friend out
here's Dale I knew this coming into this
when they asked me to do this gig I was
like listen this is gonna be a tricky
one
right cuz FIFA has a very passionate
community I know this I experienced this
firsthand when I hosted that foot
Champions Cup and you and I we talked a
lot about how important it's been for
you to engage with the audience with the
fans with the community on FIFA 20's
development so why don't we dive into
that tell me about that process and how
the community played a role in making
this game a reality for you all
absolutely community feedback is a big
deal for us the combination of community
feedback and football itself is what
inspires us every year to keep
innovating and to create the most
authentic and fun experience we can and
we know we have a big community so this
year we actually talked to over 3,000
players from pro players to new players
casual players soccer players and
because we know this is a two-way
conversation we released an important
pitch notes article at the end of May
where we explained a little bit more
about how we approached community
feedback so we listened to things like
shooting inconsistencies or AI defending
and this feedback together with our
drive to create a more authentic
football experience led us to develop a
new feature set that comes together as
football intelligence okay all right so
catchphrases are all well and good right
but let's dive into this right because I
want to be able to dive deeper into what
all this means for the player what does
football intelligence mean for the folks
that are gonna be playing in a few
months
sure football intelligence is a
combination of features that improve the
three main components of the match on
the ball of
and the wall itself and this year were
innovating in those three areas on the
wall we're enhancing the one-on-one
moments by even you knew attacking and
defending tools off the wall with a rear
keytective game flow we're giving
players more time and space on the ball
and for the ball itself we have a brand
new ball physics system that elevates
Delton dct on every touch okay so you
mentioned off the ball first that's
something that you know I'm assuming
you're talking about computer control
players there and this is a big topic
within the community I know how those
players interact with you when you're
playing the game so yeah I mean what
what is off the ball what does that mean
for us yes so off the ball if there's
something that is really going to change
how the game plays is there real
connected game flow this new game flow
was designed to give more time and space
to the dribbler and create more one once
a one-on-one is one of the most
interesting parts of football to watch
or to play if you actually play the
sport and in FIFA is gonna be the time
where user skill is going to make a
difference and while we're creating more
one-on-ones we're also encouraging more
user control defending and we are
reducing the amount of AI defensive
support that you get from your teammates
okay all right so you want to you really
want to like influence the player to be
engaged in that process yeah and I know
it seems like we're kind of just like
throwing questions out here but you know
I I guess I'm curious I'm really
interested right when I have a
controller in my hand you know what what
does this feel like you know is there
what extra space is being created with
this more player controlled approach yes
first of all the rear connected game
flow allows us to encourage smart
technical build-up based on skill so
when you score a goal you feel like you
really work for it and because you
mentioned space yes spacing is actually
one of the biggest benefits of this
system you will see how your teammates
spread around the pitch in a more
authentic way allowing you to read the
game better and also giving you new ways
for you to create your own scoring
chances and visually does the game looks
much more like like real football yeah
so my teammates are gonna be way more
helpful for me cuz lord knows I need
that all right I think you know a lot of
us feel the struggle there but now what
about the player me right as I'm as I'm
playing this game
what new tools do I have that I could
put out there on the pitch yes so
football is all about the decisive
moments on the wall and now that we're
encouraging those moments we're also
giving players that tools to make sure
those moments are in their control
there's four features that I want to
talk about composed finishing strafe
dribbling control tackling and the new
penalty kicks and free kicks all right
so four big topics yeah let's just dive
into this compose finishing what do you
mean by that sure we receive feedback
from the community regarding the
difficulty to finish in front of goal
okay so in FIFA 20 with the new compose
finishing you're going to experience
more clinical and consistent shooting
when you're in a one-on-one with the
keeper for example and if you try a more
difficult shot let's say a volley from
outside of the box then you're going to
have more chances to to miss so overall
we are improving the fundamentals of
shooting to provide a more authentic
experience and we also listen to
feedback about time finishing and that
we are very confident that the changes
that I just mentioned to the
fundamentals of shooting in addition to
some tweaks that we are doing to the
actual time finishing mechanic are going
to give you a more satisfying shooting
experience whether you time your shot or
not we are actually just releasing
another pitch notes article about this
topic do you want to know more
information you can check it online okay
so a whole topic just on this just alone
which is very dedicated there now you
also mentioned another attacking tool
which was strafe dribbling so how is
this now gonna play a role in how I play
oh good question so we are reinventing
the strafe dribbling mechanic okay this
tool lets more dimensioning attack
giving you more control more precise and
not yell control of the ball when
dribbling and I would say this tool is
great to lure your opponent in and then
when he's getting closer
use your players agility speed and skill
to beat that defender so if it wasn't
any indication though you know I I'm
gonna be on defense quite a bit Oh we'll
see because of that as a defender now
continuing to just run through these
tools these new gameplay additions that
are coming to it what about on the
defensive front yes to counter the
attacking tools we also need to bring
some innovation into defending the new
controlled tackling system which uses
the sophistication from
active touch system from last year is
going to improve your players tackling
ability to ensure you win possession
back more often than ever when you
tackle in the right context okay and
then the most intense nerve-wracking
moment I add in any game of FIFA me and
my boy Rob we went this is a everyday
thing for us penalty kicks what changes
are you making the penalty kicks we have
brand new penalty kicks and free kick
systems okay so first of all the aiming
mechanics are completely different and
more accessible but obviously we're
keeping some elements of skill in there
to make sure there's enough depth in the
mechanics for those that want to be
masters in those on those systems and
for example in free kicks you're gonna
have full control of the spin that you
apply to the ball and that's gonna
create your trajectory so you can do
side spin top spin no spin or a
combination of them and that's gonna be
based on how you swing your right stick
and then you will see the trajectory so
you can go around the wall you can go
over the wall you can do a knuckle shot
for example ultimately these systems are
are more they're more fun but do you
have more control so that you feel okay
it's more rewarding and juice basically
you swing your a stick and then you see
the trajectory being created and that's
that's the cool part so you know for
like us FPS gamers out there maybe
that's something that that I can
actually be good at you know at the
right that's awesome all right so on the
ball talk off the ball but the ball that
is the most essential part of the
beautiful game so what's new with the
ball we have a brand new ball physics
system and the bullies at the center of
every match and the innovation that
we're bringing to the ball this year
just gives you a more authentic
experience in you know yeah so we
rewrote how the ball behaves on every
player contact on every bounce on every
interaction and how spin affects the
trajectory of a shot pass or cross so
what you will see is more realistic
realistic player deflections more
realistic bounces and if you do a shot
let's say a finesse shot you will see
maybe more curve you do a lace shot you
will see like a Deeping trajectory a
rising trajectory there's more variety
in general so the entire Viva experience
feels fresh because of this new ball
physics is trying to get that ball to
some fun way is gonna create some
interesting moments added especially for
a lot of our top players out there now I
know that a lot of fans I'm sure are
gonna be very excited to try out these
new features and since you have the eyes
and ears of a ton of FIFA fans right now
floors yours anything else you want to
say to this community yes so the
features that I just talked about are
very important but there are many other
changes that we're doing in FIFA 20 and
a lot of them are based on community
feedback one of them is space we know
that sometimes slower defenders can
catch up with faster dribblers so we're
tweaking pace in FIFA 20 doesn't mean
that the entire game is gonna be based
on player speed but it just means that
player physical attributes are gonna be
slightly more important we're doing
something very similar for strength and
finally for those players that have
mastered the skill moves
we're obviously tuning some of them
let's say like our kata we're adding new
ones or if you like to change multiple
skill moves in a row then you will get a
more realistic outcome we're working on
those you tell me that text can't like
busts out like we'll see what you will
see new behaviors our text will still
find a way text will still find where
well thank you so much man I really
appreciate it now wanker players get
their hands on FIFA 20 so it's gonna be
sorry September 27th okay and there's
some good news if you have e access your
subscribe to you access you can get
hands on and September 19th Wow okay and
then of course you know EA access coming
to ps4 exactly that's good news of ps4
fans will also be able to play fifa
September 19th alright look at that
there and of course all those details
can be found online so don't forget
about that it is a hot day out here
we've been talking FIFA I've been having
a blast and Sam thank you so much man
give it for Sarah Berra once again he
can thank you awesome stuff now don't
forget if you're in LA come down T EA
play Chau if you 420 for yourself or
come watch some great street football
competition at our custom volt to pitch
keep an eye out because a FIFA team has
a lot more to come between now and
September they'll be posting deep dives
on the pitch notes platform you get more
info on gameplay career mode pro clubs
volta and because we all know you want
to talk about it FIFA Ultimate Team to
keep an eye out for those
I'm golden boy thanks so much for
watching see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
you just saw all the news on FIFA 20 in
a moment golden boy we'll be talking
with daily show host and superfan Trevor
Noah but the exciting things we just saw
do you think it's weird that golden boy
gets to talk to Trevor Noah and not me
how are ya well you know what get out of
here go go away cheese but first we've
got a very special message about EA's
play to give campaign so let's check it
out hey everyone if you're watching this
video chances are you've likely seen or
even personally experienced harassment
when playing online games in fact 57% of
players say they've been bullied or
threatened online we need to change that
absolutely games are for everyone and
the good news is we can all do something
about it EA is donating 1 million
dollars to three amazing nonprofits were
all about bullying prevention and
inclusion in games ditch the label pacer
in the United Nations he for XI you can
also help go to the link below
yeh comm slash played a gif to learn
more about these charities on their
websites they have advice on what you
can do if you're being bullied or how
you can help others who are you can also
donate any amount you can contribute
really makes a difference to these
nonprofits with the help of play to give
donations last year these charities had
sheave some pretty cool things he for
she was able to expand its message of
gender inclusivity and gaming to people
around the world ditch the label was
able to help an additional 10,000 kids
are suffering from abuse and pacer
reached 1.4 million people with
information on how to combat bullying
thanks so much everyone when we work
together we can make games of space
where everyone feels safe and included
enjoy the rest of VA play
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody golden boy
here at EA play once again and just so
you know it's always good to give back
to a great cause you can find out more
info about plate to give online now
everybody welcome to the EA play stage
the host of The Daily Show FIFA superfan
Trevor Noah thank you for having me
thank you so much for coming out man can
you know when they told me about this so
Greg obviously very salty he didn't get
to do this interview haha
Stuckey great so I I understand you are
a massive fan of FIFA well I'm not a
FIFA fan I FIFA is my full-time job and
then I do other things to sustain the
habits that's pretty much me interesting
yeah you don't you don't say that you're
a fan that's what you do that's right
Raheem Sterling is not a fan of
Manchester City he plays for the team i
play fifa professionally that's what I
do okay yeah that's my job okay fair
enough it's kind of crazy for a guy who
hosts a show called The Daily Show that
you play fifa on the daily and yet you
have to work and yet that's like luckily
this night there's nighttime as well you
gotta you gotta allocate your time
properly okay yes what you do Trevor no
elements yeah that's as confirmed all
right so so who's your who's your
favorite team again who's my favorite
team my team that's what Ultimate Team
is all about
oh really yeah okay really come on
really that's are you gonna go and
support one team when I can create the
best team ever okay I feel like I just
don't want to draw any battle lines when
it comes to the when it comes to the
English Premier League
I'm Liverpool through and through you
know I'm excited for what they did yeah
pain in Kiev joy now and then you know
when it comes to Europe I switch and I
play with different teams you know
because I get to enjoy just the players
but in the game my team is the team okay
so then who's your who's like your your
big player on your team on your ultimate
team it depends it changes depending on
what card comes out so for me right now
Syria Gomes small little man does major
things one of my favorite players in the
game I know this is a weird one right
back Almeida one of my favorite players
just like I like playing with weird
Carrie
is that no one else is playing with
because everyone out there is gonna be
playing with like 92 V air or everyone's
gonna be trying to play with Hulot's in
the middle it's just like who can you
play with Ellen not Polly one of the
best players you can play with in FIFA
mark my words going go and get him go
get him yeah yeah you just gotta get
like the weird players that no one else
likes and then like when you meet them
with your team they don't know who the
players are they don't know how they
play and that's that's what makes FIFA
such an amazing game for me is the
customization dude I tell you right now
blown away and very impressed by the way
Trevor no man just job in the knowledge
thank you thank you ever I know this was
a brief one but I want to thank you so
much for coming off the EA play my
friend I'm glad and you know FIFA 20 is
playable here and we have to have a
match I think you and I we have to have
them but we won't have a match
I will school you okay there won't be a
match yeah we can play together and then
I will I will teach you FIFA I kind of
set myself up for that one all right
well thank you buddy
in a moment
Adam rank is taking us on a deep dive on
all kinds of new features coming to
madden 20 but first power up your
exosuits freelancers because we're
talking anthem and help me get the four
one one I'm joined by anthem live
service lead producer Ben Irving hey Ben
hey man thanks having me ah thank you
for coming I can't believe you're really
here to celebrate funny games daily no
anthem at EA play what's happening of
course we're gonna come to EA play we've
got a booth out there with lots of fans
coming through to play it but really the
big thing for us this year is working
with our influences and game changes we
have our new update called the Cataclysm
on our public test server and our time
here this weekend is really about
talking to them getting feedback getting
feedback from all our players so we can
make that a great up game update all
right good
you got the mark talk to me been uh
interesting for anthem it's been an
interesting four months what have you
guys learned what are you pivoting
what's happening yeah look it's been a
wild ride you know we've learned a lot
of lessons over the last four months I
think one of the most important ones was
just around listening to play a feedback
better and so we we spent some time
really trying to get this BTS game
update out making sure instead of us
saying a player's hey this is what we
think's really exciting just give them
the game update and say you come and
tell us what are the things that you do
it like and the things that you do
like really trying to fit more into that
we can learn more from what the players
want that's what I found so fascinating
when we were talking earlier right is
the fact that the public test server is
there for people to get in and you guys
don't want to be like telling people
what school you want to start building
this game with them yeah cuz you know
doesn't matter what we think it only
matters what the players think they're
the ones playing the game so if they
love it great and if they don't they'll
tell us the feedback and we'll do our
best to address it so everybody can get
into the public test server right now
yeah it's available on PC right now if
you have access to anthem you can
download the game and play it if you
happen to be somewhere near the venue
feel free to come on in you can play it
with us as well and we just yeah like I
said really looking forward to getting
all that feedback and trying to make it
a really great game update so from there
what is the future of anthem and is
there a future of anthem that's a
question for anthem a very bright future
we hope look it's kind of the same thing
you know we've learnt a lot dis loss few
months we really want to make the game
better we believe anthem can be a really
amazing game we know we have some work
to do and we just want to work with the
community to build it together and make
it the game that everyone wants it to be
yeah well thank you Ben get back to work
you did well you didn't get a good one
getting here all right for those of you
here at EA play and those of you at home
you can get your hands on Cataclysm
right now so join me and get back in the
fight freelancers
now everyone get excited because up next
we have Adam rank bringing you an
exclusive first look at Madden gameplay
with deep dives into the new X Factor
abilities face of the franchise and more
so keep it here at EA play
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up Maddon fans I am your host
Adam rank nobody one person applause
break I wanted a bigger pop than Trevor
Noah but that's okay I'm still stoked to
be here live from EA play here in Los
Angeles now back at the NFL Draft we
revealed a ton of new features coming to
Madden 20 since then we've been asking
what you the fans want to see well guess
what we've heard those results and they
were overwhelmingly clear you guys want
rake in the game I'm in the game I don't
know if I'm not I'm not in the game I'm
sorry no we got game play we are gonna
give you actual gameplay that's coming
up in just a moment we'll be bringing
you your first look and Madden gameplay
that the ones that you've been asking
for but right now upfront we're gonna do
a quick recap of five awesome new
features coming to bat in 20 and show
you even more details let's open things
up with face of the franchise the brand
new career campaign that allows you to
create a so you can pop for that that's
cool it's a cool feature you'll be able
to create a superstar quarterback select
one of 10 d1 schools and compete in the
college football playoffs and speaking
of super star quarterbacks we sat down
with NFL MVP and Madden 20 cover athlete
Patrick mahomes to hear more about his
Superstar journey I've always loves
competing and to me there's no added
pressure there's no added expectations
that stuff that I put on myself since I
was a little kid I feel like I'm just
that same guy that's been putting in the
time and the work my whole entire life
now it's about pushing myself every
single day to get better it's about
passion I'm going out there having fun
you have to make sure that you're just
evolving never being satisfied with
where you're at
coming to the league it seems like every
single year there's some different guy
that's just faster and stronger and
bigger and so with the different ways to
get better and those are the guys that
find ways to win in the end every single
year from college to come into the
league and as my career goes on I just
keep getting better and better at the
approach from each play and recognized
what you do it has success the first
time I ever ran out the tunnel in front
that crowd it was a surreal feeling and
I'll never forget it
my expectation was to learn a Super Bowl
and I fell just short of that you used
that stuff as motivation this is just
the beginning oh wow Patrick mahomes
give it up he's amazing he's an amazing
quarterback he's living the journey that
you'll be taking on in face of the
franchise and joining me right now is
Madden community manager Israel Cruz aka
agent K figure it's a little more
information on face of the franchise as
well as some of the other exciting
features that are coming - what are you
doing hey it's great to be you know you
look a little crispy up top and you know
me too so I brought you all this but uh
yeah this is our seven and three-quarter
although there's a guy in a Khalil Mac
tur take off the Chiefs cap put this on
hey there you go don't give away those
see you gotta protect the noggin man
thank you so much you know over the last
few weeks we've been talking about
Madden 20 on live streams and it's been
great our community has been really
engaged and we've been asking them
questions what do you want to see here
at EA play and this is the culmination
we took their feedback we're gonna talk
a little bit about those things and
regarding face of the franchise
our players wanted to see an NFL draft
experience I like what's going on so
you'll see when one of these screens
right here what's really great is you're
going into the NFL draft sequence right
here you're in the green room you know
your players a little bit nervous
representing the Texas Longhorns go
horns and has a cheeseburger right there
so yes it's still Los Angeles the rose
ball from a couple of years ago it's
still looming large though so be cool
with that well listen don't get mad at
me just stop Vince Young all right so
here's the thing so what so this is all
awesome I love the detail there once you
get drafted what you're now in franchise
mode and all that stuff and I hear the
Pro Bowl is coming back - what else
should Madden fans now yes it's really
cool the Pro Bowl is back in Madden 20
when you're going to go ahead install
the game you're going to be able to play
the Pro Bowl get your hands on those
superstar X factors play with them a
little bit but our franchise players are
one to see more
the scenario engine and we're gonna go
show a little bit about that now the
scenario engine what it does it brings
dynamic quests kinda changes into the
game that help you improve your player
and their ratings week to week so that's
pretty awesome but you said it earlier
people want to see more about gameplay
so we're gonna go ahead and talk about
gameplay and start a blog where they can
check all that stuff out there yes there
is we've written quite a few blogs we
have gridiron notes which you can go
ahead and search the web you'll find
those but we also have a franchise deep
dive blog that details everything out
coming to franchise in man 20 okay for
all the play callers and armchair
coaches what else can they look forward
to you know like real estate its like
location location location people want
playbooks play books playbook snores now
this year Madden 20 we're having RP o is
coming into the game with your grunt
pass options which was great but not
just that but our players have been
asking for new formations so right here
we have out of the Raiders playbook
unique formation which has which is
actually called double a single back
double off close and what's great about
this is a PA sweep play we've got going
on right here which is absolutely great
our players are excited about that but
what I'm excited about is that
throughout the course of the season
we're gonna go ahead and evolve those
play books and as things happen in the
NFL we're gonna bring that stuff to the
NFL yeah I see the one Derek Carr fan
out there was very excited to see that
Raiders playbook I know that we've got a
lot of I'm sorry two Raider fans wear
jersey next time I can't identify you
without it it's okay listen I'm talking
to Israel though here's the thing now
we've got a lot of matted ultimate team
fans in the house am i right they want
to know more about the content they need
to be bringing to the table tell us a
little bit more about those ultimate
missions yeah so ultimate missions are
great a lot of times our madden ultimate
team players when they log into the game
they're always trying to find the most
up-to-date content so one of the things
this year that we're trying to do is
provide them kind of a guide and
information hub so then when they log in
they're not spending all that time
looking in different areas they can get
the player items that they want for
their team to make the best squad
possible hey hey hey hey I heard that
so one of the things that's absolutely
great let's say Khalil Mack has an
amazing game on Sunday you know you log
into mad mad no to a team you want to be
able to find it so basically we're going
to go ahead and provide you that in for
me
guy that step-by-step process so you can
get that item on your team now the Clio
Mac fan sitting here loves hearing that
the guys the two Raider fans over here
not so much whatever we appreciate a
little switching guys I know that
talking about the Rose Bowl being too
soon yeah we love the Raiders I love
John grit and what he's done for our
team now the most thing that the thing
that I'm most excited for though is the
superstar x-factor abilities these make
the superstars you know play like
superstars and eager you're gonna give
us a little bit of a reveal and some of
these abilities yeah so our players have
been asking us to go ahead and talk
about these super star X factors the
first one we're gonna reveal is alvin
kamara
which is great is he has his own
abilities he also has superstar
abilities and we're gonna go and take a
look right here
what's cool about his own abilities
called satellite you've you've heard of
satellite back I know what it is yeah
okay so yeah I mean these guys yeah so
at the end of the day I mean you know
you guys have seen the tape out of the
backfield Kamara's a deep threat as a
wide receiver as a receiver just it's
crazy he's absolutely amazing out of the
backfield but he also has superstar
abilities so the superstar abilities are
matchup nightmare so basically you're
gonna go ahead have better opportunities
to go ahead and catch the ball against
linebackers and DBS and also better
route running I mean he's absolute beast
and he also has running back apprentice
we're running back apprentice actually
does for him is that it allows him to
have four additional hot routes anytime
and pre-play adjustments love fat now
listen everybody who knows me knows I'm
kind of a dumb guy so can you explain
the difference between zone abilities
and superstar abilities yeah so for zone
abilities we talked about satellite so
what it's gonna happen is in game you're
gonna go ahead and get some in-game
objectives on how to go ahead and get
your player in the zone and you know
Clint's gonna talk a little bit here
about how you knock them out of the zone
but the thing is is that superstar
abilities what that's gonna allow you to
do is that it's it's they're always
available they're always on and not just
that but it brings like a unique
authentic feel to that specific player
so what Kamara one of the things that we
were actually showing right there is
that it's going to allow him to go ahead
and do some amazing things out of the
backfield it's just another level of
authenticity is what's everything
totally I mean our players have been
asking us for a long time they want the
players to feel like nfl superstars when
they're on the field and we want to give
that to them okay now to help us get
even more
down and dirty and some of those details
on x-factor abilities I want everybody
right now this is serious put your hands
together because joining us here on the
stage here in just a moment is one of
the best wide receivers on the planet
from the Pittsburgh Steelers from the
University of Southern California a
hardcore mad and fed ladies and
gentlemen all the way in the back give
it up for juju Smith Schuster
[Applause]
[Applause]
there it is the crowd loves juju right
[Applause]
you guys oh my goodness you know what
thank you so much for coming out and we
always appreciate you taking the time
and interacting with the community and
everything how are you enjoying your
time here at EA play I'm loving it it's
awesome it's a blessing to be here you
see the fans and still her fans look at
I was here last year and it was amazing
setup and to come back again no question
and you know I heard about Madden 20 and
I heard about paddle holes being on the
cover and the whole X Factor thing I was
like wow this is amazing
now you mate you had a monster year once
again you know you're obviously one of
the best players in the league kind of
go through the thought process when
you're on the field you're in zone you
see single coverage what are you
thinking when I see that one-on-one it's
the opportunity of me getting the ball
you know knowing that the defense is
coming and what if I have to put the
wall a lot faster and all right you can
think it my head is like catch the ball
get yak yard score touchdown
celebrations and pretty much in my head
I'm just like wow like let's make a play
big place and you make big player what
do you you had a 97 yard reception or
did you have to yeah it's a oh yeah
that's right I'm sorry to me to sell you
sorry now in addition to getting all
those yak yards you're also known for
wrestling away those jump balls so it's
no surprise to me that your zone ability
is double meat is it cool if we take a
look yeah check it out yeah so what you
guys are gonna see right here would you
like Jude you said once he gets that
single coverage and he is in the zone
there is no stopping him
the only way that you're gonna be able
to stop him is to go ahead and double
cover and at the end of the day you know
it's a it's a new meta to the game if
you want to stop juju you got a double
cover um well first of all you can't
stop them let's just put that out there
right now what did you think do you
think we nailed it but if that's awesome
that's crazy that's definitely something
I you know I see myself doing you know
the double coverage stretching this year
to be super gas ID and I just can't wait
you're not having an X Factor I can't
wait to you know use it in the game use
myself in the game are you ready to
check it out e excited to start playing
super excited all right well you're in
luck because we've got Madden 20
playable right here at EA play you an
agent K can go try it out agent K is
there any way that our fans at home can
maybe try this out as well well you know
I think a lot of people that are here
are go
to get a chance to go and check out our
closed open us our closed beta that's
going to be happening from Madden 20
it's gonna be happening on June 14 to
the 16th but I believe over at the madam
Booth we're giving out some codes you
guys have may have seen it so if you
haven't checked it out go over to the
booth there's going to be a blog up I
believe man-of-the-people Z Falls is
going to go ahead and be talking about
that putting out check out our social
channels all that information is there I
brought a couple of codes here for juju
we're gonna give juju some codes as well
we're also going to be sharing on social
channels check that out a lot of great
information
you want some Adam Butte mater all right
here you go but no it's not just that
but we're gonna work with juju he's
gonna be giving out codes on his channel
so again
tune in to our social channels all the
information there about the closed beta
happening on June 14th the June 16 but
since you're here you guys can grab it
early download it and get ready for June
14 all right thank you so much for
coming out Israel to to go play the game
go play they get a little round of
applause juju Smith Schuster there he
goes
handing out those codes I don't know
that you're gonna get those back I don't
know if he's gonna all right well juju
is gonna go get a taste of what Madden
20 is all about but don't don't go
anywhere guys cuz we've got even more
Madden 20 gameplay to show you right now
cuz please welcome to the stage our
senior gameplay designer Clint Oldenburg
put it together everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
keep it going
gonna see you do it wonderful
oh my gosh thank you so much for being
here now we've seen those x-factor
abilities but I want to dig a little bit
deeper tell me a little bit more about
how they impact gameplay that's a great
question I'm gonna follow with a
question for you for okay and I'm
trusting you to give me the right answer
you got what are some reasons you like
to watch football I like yelling at my
fantasy players that's a good one okay
anything else oh you know what I like
watching superstars play like superstars
but do you have somebody like juju Smith
Schuster I want to see him make some big
plays that's exactly right
I'm sorry that you have to follow it it
was a really hard assignment Trevor Noah
Jude you and now Clint yeah yeah so you
mentioned superstars the NFL is such a
star driven league madden is no
different we set out with a creative
vision this year to make our stars feel
like stars so we created this ability
system known as super star X Factor's
these abilities are gonna bring
authentic skills that make these guys
feel unique and powerful so that every
individual game is unique and game plan
differently and that's what it's all
about authenticity and that's great that
you guys take that extra level of
realism can we see some more X factors
in action can we you know we talked
about mahomes at the start of the show
I'd love to see him go out there and do
his thing if that's pot we got some cool
stuff to show you here with Patrick
mahomes our cover athlete bazooka is his
own ability now to get into the zone you
have to do an in-game objective with
mahomes you have to complete four passes
of 30 yards or more and once you get
inside the zone denoted there by his
x-factor icon he can throw the ball
further than anyone else in the game his
max past distances increased about 15
yards to about 80 you can bomb the
everybody's doing an dieing I mean
that's what we see on Sunday now you
talked about the air yards it's got to
be air yard right not dump on a Mian
Williams
exactly four passes of 30 yards or more
that's traveling in the air 30 yards so
the rack yards don't count and this all
makes sense because obviously mahomes
has a hell in arm but can all
quarterbacks make throws like that or is
this just exclusive to him bazooka is
exclusive to patch mahomes I mean he's
got the big arm he's on record
as throwing an 83 yard pass we may be
selling him a little bit short but
listen this is not a gimmick ability
these things are inspired by their
real-life skills that make them special
so that's his own ability does he have
any others yes he also has superstar
abilities as an X as an X Factor one of
our better X factors he has his own
ability and then superstar abilities
we're gonna break down his loadout here
right here we got escape artist first
and as everyone knows he's a dual threat
quarterback escape artist gives him
elite agility and speed when scrambling
on passing the place looks like mahomes
right yes unfortunately I mean that's
what he does
and a dashing Deadeye gives him perfect
passing accuracy when throwing on the
run so it's a nice little combo there
perfect passing accuracy is the best
accuracy you can have in our game and
then here's a red zone yeah red zone
Deadeye if you watched him last year you
know he was deadly in the red zone when
he's inside the 20-yard line
again perfect passing accuracy lastly no
look that I'm really excited about this
one he's gonna have perfect accuracy the
only quarterback in the game at lunch to
have perfect accuracy on cross body
throws exclusive to him is the no-look
signature Mahone that's animation that's
his signature look that's exactly what
he does every Sunday and everybody gets
upset about it and this is the thing
though I know mahomes I get it he plays
like a star but come on this is kind of
a lot is he unbeatable is there i if I'm
on the other side of the ball like what
can I do to stop them now you must play
Madden because that question our pet no
it's frustrating
yeah it's a chess match so just like in
the NFL the way to shut down a
high-power passing game is pass rush the
defense is gonna have knockout
conditions when these guys are in the
zone you're gonna see here in mahomes
with his x-factor icon lit up he's in
the zone von Miller's gonna sack them
the objective for the Broncos in this
game sack mahomes knock him out of the
zone so each team's gonna have ways to
counter each other so again it's it's
it's authentic football conditions it's
a chess matches all that stuff exactly
and if you pull that objective off you
knock him out of the zone then he has to
go through his objectives again to get
back into the zone all right well that's
a little bit reassuring I'm glad that
there's some checks and balances that go
along with all that stuff but we all
know I know you're an offensive guy but
defense wins championships we've seen
what the offense can do let's talk about
the defensive side of the ball you know
I want to see what
the most incredible athletes in the NFL
regardless of position
Aaron Donald what's he all about yeah
Mary yeah give him a fair and Donald
heir Donald is scary
so I played offensive line when I play
and I knew I couldn't block him in this
chair
so he's reflected pretty well he's got
his own ability called fearmonger okay
what makes him special is when he gets
in the zone he can actually apply
pressure penalties to the quarterback
even when he's engaged in a block
typically those penalties only occur
when you're free rush unblocked to the
quarterback he does it while he's
blocked we're gonna take a look at some
of these he also has superstar abilities
well he's out he's in the video there
there was the pressure penalty applied
to the quarterback right in addition to
that he has pass rush elite that's a
superstar ability that gives him quicker
faster pass rush ed moves as a pass
rusher and then under pressure makes
those penalties he's applying to the
throw power and throw accuracy the
quarterback more punitive so he's a
quite a disruptive pass rusher cuz
that's one of the things too it's not
necessarily especially with somebody
who's playing defensive tackle it's not
somebody who's always going out there
and getting sacks it's guys who are
going out there and also getting
pressure up the middle
pushing offensive linemen into the face
of the quarterback yeah it lends itself
to more strategy in the game you got to
know who you're playing against you got
to know who you're playing with like I
said it's a chess match out there and
then one important note here with all
the passing abilities you said my home
seemed really powerful putting pressure
on the quarterback is going to be the
direct counter to a lot of those
abilities and that takes them off their
game and that takes them off an x-factor
and everything like absolutely so it's
good to have those guys one of the cool
things too that I've noticed when you're
watching all that all the play and all
that stuff going on is that you've
worked really hard to bring these guys
unique abilities to life and put their
personalities out there and that
includes some custom animations so what
are some of the examples of these custom
animations working on these are super
cool we didn't want our superstars to
just feel great we want them to look
great too the first place is quarterback
cover athlete Patrick mahomes we went
out and captured these guys signature
passing animations we have covered for
about six to seven over the most popular
quarterbacks in the game we're going to
continue to add to these throughout the
year Aaron Rodgers quick release
drew Brees you know he's always
fidgeting if you're a Saints fan and
it's tense beyond quarterbacks
everyone knows Zeke Elliot's feed me
getting
team in the zone these animations you
know celebrations throw styles it's to
connect with your favorite players
connect with your superstars on the
field what you saw like why why we saw
the thing with Ezekiel Elliott somebody
who's a Cowboys fan or just likes
watching and play that they can identify
with they start cheering and they like
seeing that kind of stuff I don't like
seeing Aaron Rodgers leave his feet and
throw the ball 90 yards down the field
but whatever we don't we don't have to
get into that Khalil max all right guys
you know what we've talked a lot about
the new features what about player
mechanics cuz as a player what I like
some of the the tools in my toolbox so
to speak nailed it with the tool box
yeah we're always looking at ways to add
new new mechanics the game give our
players more control there's two that we
want to go over today and they're both
for the quarterback the first is the new
scramble mechanic or pulldown mechanic
what this does is give you the ability
on a passing play to pull down the
passing icons with a button press become
a ball carrier all right full access to
all the spin moves Jukes ball carrier
moves and then you can bring back your
icons again with the same button press
and throw it at any time makes any
quarterback a dual threat bring some
skill here with Ben Roethlisberger we're
looking at the new pump fake mechanic
you can now pump fake to a specific
receiver on the rule but double tapping
the button you're gonna see the reticle
come up to get guys to bite on it it
could dual purpose mechanic you can also
use it to pull down if you feel like
you've made a poor decision and you want
to cancel the throw just quickly double
tap it you'll pull it back down so you
can you know kind of pump fake it to an
outside guy and then check it down to a
tight end or something like that
absolutely you can even use it on double
moves if you want juju to run a slant
and go okay pump faking on the slant
take him deep oh that's amazing there's
this keeps getting better and you know
this you played in the NFL not too long
ago but the game has changed so much in
the in the number of years since you've
been gone we've seen a lot of college
coaches come in and they've brought in
their offenses and a most recently Kliff
Kingsbury down there in Arizona bringing
in his high-powered offense Kyler Murray
you know not a prototypical quarterback
he's shorter but they're gonna do a lot
of that run-pass option are you bringing
that into the game yes super excited to
announce that we are delivering our POS
as they're known I mean you know you
can't watch an NFL broadcast not hearing
that acronym or all they talked about
1314 times right so this is a concept
taking the entire football world by
storm
we actually have three
different types of RP O's in our game we
have alert speaks and reads I'm going to
break those down really quick for our
players the first is an alert that's a
very basic pre-snap read you're calling
a running play and you're gonna look at
what the defense is aligned in if you
think you can run the play you just call
the play you hit nothing you'll hand it
off and away you go
however what's cool about those places
you can branch out of that handoff at
any time just by hitting the receiver
icon and throw it if he's open so that's
a really cool way to be creative on
offense and then there's two other types
that peek more similar to a read option
you're reading a single defender on
defense looking at his behavior after
the snap if he bites on run you could
pull it out throw to your receiver and
if he sits back on past you just hold
the button down hand it off to the
running back gain yards on the ground
lastly the read this is more like the
traditional triple option play you're
gonna read two to three defenders after
the snap look at their behavior then
decide if you want to hand it off to
your running back keep it with your
quarterback or throw it to the receiver
we actually have over 200 RPO plays in
our play books the 220 that's a lot that
is very impressive and it sounds like
you've built in a lot more flexibility
are there any other formations or plays
coming to the game oh yeah you're gonna
see if there's any Eagles fans in here
you're gonna see something cool here in
a minute we got new animation technology
as part of our RPO story so we were able
to put in a lot of these cool concepts
you're seeing the NFL right now Philly
special is in the game later on the
gameplay right here there it is right
there we also have a lot of jet sweet
touch pass concept you're seeing the
Chiefs and the Rams teams like that
using end arounds you're gonna see a lot
of fresh unique content in the play
books and the cool thing is we're gonna
be updating the play books all season
long to make sure that we're staying
up-to-date with the NFL this is all
amazing thank you so much Klan I cannot
wait for this game we've we've dropped a
lot of awesome info here about Madden 20
here at EA play that's what I say once
again I'm Adam rank if you want even
more mad in 20 News you can tune in to
the Madden channel right after this but
before we finish up though I've got one
last treat for you player ratings
they're one of the trickiest things to
get right in Madden well in addition to
being a game designer Clint uses his
background as a former NFL player to
help make sure that those ratings are
accurate and are
over at ESPN have helped to put together
a little video to give us the scoop on
the best job in the world
the Madden ratings adjuster let's roll
it this is good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a 90 over ah my bad rating is Harb it's
tre we're trying to make our game match
what these players are doing in real
life I would like sake Lombardi's jump
to the accurately rated give me like 93
94 and if they think that we have it
wrong they're gonna let us go back to
the 90 grand
thank you my cat dragon gotta go up a
little bit I can't be dropping pics on
Matt I need my speed up just turn the
notch up a little bit for you where mine
sucks who does my man ratings hey I'm
Quinn Oldenburg I'm a Matt and rating
performance adjuster
[Music]
between those new x-factor abilities
face of the franchise and the RP oh and
all that gameplay mana fans have a lot
to be excited about and now I can't wait
for our final show of the day it's more
epic than star wars more extreme than
battlefield and more competitive than
Matta FIFA apex legends combined that's
right I'm talking about the sims before
we talk Simlish the apex legends Watson
reveal earlier has inspired me to come
up with some legend ideas of my own so
I'm now joined by apex legend game
designer Griffon Dean has agreed to hear
my feedback Griffin to you what makes a
great legend so in a lot of ways it has
to do with the way that they interact in
the ecosystem of characters and a lot of
sort of acquitting interesting
interactions and choices for players so
a lot of it has to do with sort of the
way that the legends work together as a
unit rather than them individually
alright well I didn't really base my
picks or my descriptions on there but I
can work on the fly first off tell you
about the grappler the graphic grappler
okay things okay we could be taking
people's ammunition okay did it take
that you know you put your pings up you
could take away pain okay is he a kidnap
or you might not you might ask he's not
above it it doesn't define himself as a
kidnapper but he's not above it so I
like the name it seems like you could do
a thing we're like teammates items just
appear in his inventory as his passive
and like I don't know where these came
from it writes itself it does right
there I was thinking about with this
taller Gibraltar taller Gibraltar but
talk winch's talk wenches it's enough
that you notice but not enough where
you're like freaked out I don't know if
the level can support that hip Hawks the
I thought you got I thought you called
yourself a video game developer huh you
know all right
you know I your easier this is this is
what about Portillo Portillo it is he's
my wiener dog a lot of people have
problem with me on the internet no one
ever has a problem for telling okay
you know that's think yeah somatically I
could I could see that working is and
then
what about Dwayne the rock Johnson huh
no explanation needed yeah no that's
yeah you just I feel like there'd be a
lot of wrestling involved well I mean
he's easy braver that's true understand
the rock go over there okay to work on
these ideas all right VIN said I had
just a blank check all right all right
what do you think hey if it isn't Golden
Boy himself how you doing you killing it
I've got to see you today I know I know
a little bit about Dwayne the rock
Johnson yeah I know tight and games NBC
whatever just hang time now your big
deal throwing it out there throwing it
out there all those ideas by the way
we're freakin awful several Portillo for
yellow Portillo's a winner for toes the
only thing that gets me over everything
else you're getting buried well furtillo
always over Alex what was it like
talking to Trevor now hey Trevor Noah's
awesome did not expect him to be as
hardcore of a FIFA fan as he was he like
yeah quitter he schooled me like
straight up yeah I respect that yeah
yeah yeah I like going toe to toe with a
what a fellow wordsmith on this age you
know all right fine
ladies and gentlemen what did you think
of Trevor Noah let us know in the chat
sure someone's looking at it but right
now we are not done yet everybody get
excited because we're finishing EA plays
strong with an in-depth look at what's
new for The Sims 4 including the world
exclusive reveal of a brand new pad stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh you guys are great
welcome semistate I play I'm very
excited to talk about everyone's
favorite game series the sim oh yeah I'm
Judy Hardy and today we're giving you a
guided tour of what's new with the
sevens for plus a couple of fun
surprises so stay tuned now to help me
translate all of this Simlish everybody
join me in welcoming general manager
Lindsay Pearson and senior producer
Michael G much for coming out guys so
I'm super excited I know you guys are
super excited yeah absolutely I've been
with the Sims a long time and this is
one of my favorite things to do is come
out and see all of you and tell you
exciting things absolutely and I mean
it's gonna be a big year for us it's
actually we're celebrating 20 years of
making the Sims this year yeah and
Lindsay and I keep debating it but I
think this is gonna be the best year yet
I think it might be well I mean really
what we want to know is what have you
not for us come on of course well it is
EA play we couldn't come empty-handed so
we'll start with our big one first I'll
let you take that absolutely so we have
the next expansion pack for The Sims 4
Sims 4 island living let's check out
that trailer yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so cool and look we're in our
own little island parents can I just say
I didn't know what the reveals were
gonna be and is is dead look at all this
super weird
oh and obviously you know talking about
fashion there's a lot of Island fashion
they're one of the biggest things people
absolutely love and what can we be what
can be dressing up as what can we look
like absolutely you know to capture that
Island spirit we needed to have a lot of
new outfits and capture those not
exactly that but certainly those bright
colors like you're showing off there but
you know we really wanted to add a lot
of island wear and that stuff you can
stay cool and when it's so hot it's true
yeah and we had to bring in a lot of new
fun colors and patterns but also hair's
accessories everything to deck out head
to toe to just chill and relax on this
beautiful island and I mean that's some
amazing fashion of that but what if you
know I'm getting a little bit hot I'm
not someone who likes to dwell on a
beach you're not yeah what if I want to
go in the water what's gonna be
happening there so we're very excited so
for the first time in the Sims for our
Sims are going to be able to walk right
into the open water yeah open water game
play I mean like you saw on the trailer
she walks right in our sins are gonna be
able to do that and you can snorkel in
the water there's swimming floating and
there's also those pretty awesome aqua
zips yeah in a hurry to get where you're
going inspired you guys to introduce
this kind of ocean gameplay this time
yeah well we've taken the Sims to a lot
of different worlds in a lot of
different places but we hadn't yet
really played with the idea of where the
land and the water meets and really
bring you bring you into an ocean
environment which seems like a great
addition absolutely I mean you know when
I think of tropical islands I'm thinking
of you know like palm trees ocean waves
relaxing on the beach so like tell me
more about this world what can I
actually do in it yes so the island of
Salani will have all of those things and
more it really is the perfect place to
unplug and enjoy this natural feel so
you can explore all these little alcoves
you can live closer to the coast or you
can live higher higher up towards the
hills or what's right wait
there's an active volcano okay you just
thought you were selling me the dream of
living on an island now I'm not sure I
really want to go through that it is a
real island motive islands are formed by
volcanoes yeah picky yeah so we had to
put this active volcano in there now you
don't have to live next to it but the
riskier Sims may choose to live near oh
oh yeah bombs
oh the sims I don't I don't know how
that was gonna be when you touch
something that's really really hot
that's beautiful locale slightly
dangerous what other surprises are in
store on this island I mean I for one
want to know if I can befriend any kind
of cute animals what kind of animals
don't meet the friends well I mean it
wouldn't be the Sims if we didn't let
you make friends with some of the
animals that I'm so in this case the one
we're really excited about is the
dolphin our art team animators just blew
away expectation I'm just going off to
somewhere hot to do that they're so cute
and you get to make like a really nice
friend with them and maybe it'll do
tricks for you or squirt water in your
face
absolutely well and then we also we
added a bunch of tropical fish to the
water too so we really wanted to get
those coral reefs around the island to
feel lush and fall and so that meant
more fish lay I mean I think I mean I
don't know we don't have fish like that
in the UK I mean we might do but the
water is so murky I mean what do you put
with the chips I mean I I think the
Islanders this looks so relaxing
obviously is not really about vacation
it's also you know it's it's about kind
of working there as well but like um
what's kind of like the feeling the vibe
of the island gonna be like you know I
think it's one of those things we talked
a lot about in the team is capturing
what it would be like to really live on
that island it's not just a place you
vacation but we wanted this to be a
place that's home for your sense you
know it makes to be played on you well
that happens too well so there's lots to
do on the beach you saw Sun Tanning Sun
burning light holding day hassles the
whole family can go out and play
together find seashells or the
mischievous Sims you know
things down well in aqua zips there what
are they called again aqua okay yeah
it's there's a lot to look at so you've
got to take time to really explore it
all okay so obviously we've established
that Solaria is like a great place there
seems to kind of kick back and you know
what if my sims you know they don't want
to like I can't personally lie on a
beach for looking about thirty minutes
get ready bored what if they want to get
their hands dirty well I'm very excited
about a new thing that we're introducing
if your sims want a new career to take
care of this island you can actually
become a conservationist and your job is
gonna be to keep this ecosystem looking
beautiful yeah I mean it's certainly one
of the big goals was a way for your sims
to kind of care for their world yeah and
make it a better place yeah obviously
you know very relevant with everything
that's going on today in the world and
how everyone's kind of a lot more kind
of aware so was that kind of what
inspired you guys to bring that in you
know I think there's a few things that
really hit us I mean the first was just
it's something we all care about a lot
of us on the dev team worry about the
environment what's going on but we
talked about the idea that this islands
this closed ecosystem and so your
actions and choices are gonna have a lot
more impact and so something new we've
added here and we're really excited
about is the island actually changes
over time so if you're taking care of it
it'll actually become more lush you'll
see more greenery brighter beautiful
flowers and there's Lindsey's favorite
part more butterflies
cats bats but also today happens to be
World Oceans Day which is amazing it's
that's exactly what we were talking
about take care of these ecosystems
salon is really beautiful
you know you can kind of go out there
but like someone you want to make a
little bit of cash I mean you know like
barbecue meat I presume is expensive
I don't know but so how can we make some
extra samolians well we wanted to make
this place you live yeah you've got to
have a way to earn some Somali yeah I'm
sure yeah Pia has to end sometime
money as much so we added a couple like
odd jobs and things that you could kind
of work on the hours you wanted to right
and so we've added the ability to make
fishing more of a career and then also
the lifeguard so you can get your tan
while you're working if you want to
spend more time in the water you can be
a dive instructor there's a lot of
different ways to just pick up a job
when you want and earn a little bit of
money yeah so it's based on the
important things as well as
not a vacation as you are kind of living
on this island obviously you know you
have to kind of be aware and know what's
kind of part of local culture because
you're not just there on holiday and you
go in and go out you're living there so
what kind of you know the side of the
culture of the island can we actually
see within right yeah this is a place
that you live and the locals are super
friendly actually and are gonna come and
help you out with all sorts of different
things as you tour the island like
actually like all the neighbors are
really really helpful and help ya can
help you you know like if a fire happens
to break out your neighbor might bust in
and help you put out there so but they
also have their own traditions their own
sort of activities that you might be
able to join in so you might stumble
across barbecue that they've started in
town or a little festival to sort of
celebrate things going on and you might
even stumble into a comma party sorry
well a kava policy what's a coffee so a
kava is a special Island drink that your
sim can learn how to make and share with
their friends on the island it's one of
the many delicacies you'll learn kind of
exploring life in Suwanee yeah I think
it's one of those things we talked about
was we wanted to have this island have a
little history to it just some sense of
feeling of some people have lived here a
long time and there are traditions that
are unique to this place the world of
Salani we kind of learn more about the
islands history like when we're there
how do we do that aside from you know
drinking kava that might be one
experience right but on top of that
something else the team was really
excited about adding is there these
elementals around the island that are
kind of these spirits these ancients who
care a lot about suwanee and you know
they want to see their world taken care
of and when you do good things they
might be really happy and pleased and if
you're bad to the island I don't think
they may not stick in the tail yeah and
we also we added some new traits with
this pack that we wanted to really let
if your sims are super in touch with the
land or that's important to you you know
they can really get in touch with the
water or the land and unlock some new
behaviors okay so from what we've kind
of seen in all the videos it feels
really inspired by like Polynesian
culture so how do I kind of go about
kind of educating yourself to like bring
that into the game well every time we
make a world we want to learn a lot
about the influences that could go into
that place because it's not a particular
real place but it's inspired by a real
place
so short of flying there and researching
it ourselves we reached out I'm sorry
yeah well he is a big global company so
we were able to reach out to a lot of
our friends and co-workers across the
company and say hey we're looking at
exploring a place inspired by this
culture yeah and could you share with us
some patterns or iconography or symbols
or even items that mean something to
this culture right so we can try and
create them in a way that feels rich and
feels authentic questions just like what
was iconic to you or what do you
remember when you think back to living
in that place right and some of our
specific like decor items came exactly
from those recommendations which is
really cool it's these nice touches that
I hope make it feel familiar while still
feeling like a new Sims world so not to
make light of all that because I think
that's fantastic I really feel like I've
been quite patient up into this point
and you haven't really mentioned it yet
mermaids mermaids mermaids tell us
everything here are mermaids yes so
mermaids are in the pack and I know lots
of players are gonna be wondering it is
a very fully feature to call it you can
take him into casts you can create and
style your mermaid lots of different
tales it's a lot of fun but also you
know the mermaids they can do a little
bit more obviously they're very in touch
with the ocean life mm-hmm so you know
I'd recommend your mermaid meet a
dolphin might work out for you but
lastly the mermaids have some some
pretty cool powers that you might want
they're definitely worth exploring so I
can't wait for you guys to get your
hands on them so of course I would just
love to keep talking about mermaids but
no conversation about this it would be
complete without a chat about obviously
interior design so kind of what's new
for the architects about there yeah
gnomes you found it sure we saw some I
pretty sure we saw some houses on stilts
as well over the water right yeah so I
think you know first and foremost lounge
chairs we're gonna go to islands we're
gonna live the beach life I'm sorry no
awkward sitting on the snow we've had to
bring the lounge chairs in but then also
a lot of that decor to really capture
that Polynesian feel right and so we
wanted to make sure there was that
clutter that felt authentic and let it
feel like this was home
yeah and you can go for this more sort
of local style Cabana on the beach or
you can go for something a little more
high-end in modern we really wanted you
to feel like you could create the like
getaway of your dreams yeah for sure
yeah I'm so 100% sold on the houses over
the water I'm a kind of modern sort of
house yeah for sure and you might have
noticed who she was able to jump right
off of that deck out into the water
which is the rest like your perfect
little escape oh good I'm feeling the
diving into the water vibe I know I
can't wait to check out obviously the
new island living expansionpak and now
that I've got a feeling out that some of
you you know that you've got some more
exciting additional information as well
for so it's not just that you know you
have some more news in fact we're gonna
kick to somebody else for this
announcement all right no here's Joey
Graceffa oh hello there everyone I'm and
if you didn't know I absolutely love the
Sims and I'm so excited to announce this
upcoming partnership with one of my
favorite games so this summer the Sims
is actually partnering with the amazing
it gets better project as part of this
partnership with it gets better Sims is
going to be releasing bright items in
all the Sims
products in the next few months there's
going to be a variety of it gets better
and pride clothing in a Sims FreePlay at
the zoo's mobile app and Sims 4 there's
even a gender-neutral bathroom in Sims 4
along with a bunch of other items to
show off your pride thanks so much for
letting me share this news with everyone
now go out and enjoy your EA play that's
so cool to see that's really really cool
to see and thanks so much to Joey for
showing for that I mean what a great
partnership as well to be announcing of
course cuz it's it's you know it's Pride
Month it's Pride Week here in Los
Angeles how are you guys going about
kind of supporting that great cause well
The Sims has always been a game about
being inclusive and the self-expression
of creating yourself and people you know
and telling your own story so this is a
wonderful opportunity to bring new
content in the game to celebrate that
definitely and I think also people don't
realize how important it is sometimes
you know when you're kind of growing up
and you're figuring out who you are
you're discovering what kind of person
you are and discovering you know about
your sexuality and able to kind of sort
of role play within game
is a really really safe place to do that
so you know you guys have been doing it
pretty much from the start way before
everyone else so it's really great I
mean it's not great to see it's so so
great yeah well it's something we're
very proud of and having been with the
game a long time it's something that
keeps making me excited about being able
to do more yeah I love when we get to do
stuff like that you know it just it
makes what we do feel so much more
powerful and meaningful and you know
it's I always be getting to tell people
that I work on this game amazing stuff
you know and also when we get to hear
from our community about the experiences
they've had or how the game helped them
get through a tough time in their life
or realize something about themselves
it's just that stuff really keeps us
going as develop our 'fl gaming is and
how much it can really kind of affect
and change you as a person and show you
stuff it's um it's amazing so when can
we get our hands on it yeah so Joey
mentioned briefly but it's starting June
18th
the pride content will come to the Sims
4 and then it will start rolling out
over the Sims mobile and the Sims
FreePlay a little bit later so keep an
eye out for that absolutely I mean it
that's great but I mean I think you've
actually got them this is such a
ridiculous and at lace backed about
right what else you've got something
else that you want to announce in the
summer we actually had I think two more
things we wanted to tell you I'm gonna
Lindsay talk about this all right so
first of all earlier this year we
announced our partnership with mosquito
by releasing a real world capsule
collection of looks inspired by the Sims
I see some of them and I'm very excited
we had a hoodie that was actually put
into all of our Sims games so later this
summer we're gonna be bringing that
fashion and more to the sims for
mosquito stuff pack hazing yes so not
only are we gonna be looking pretty
special but what if we want to kind of
go and strut our stuff somewhere else
and like really show off the outfits
that we've got well so I think one of
the things that I'm most excited about
in this stuff pack is for the first time
we're actually gonna add a career as
part of a stuff back so we've decided
the perfect career for this pack okay a
part-time job is a freelance fashion
photographer so you can capture all
those amazing looks
yes can now rock that's so me yes
gonna be fun I'm excited Wow we've
covered so much so far a new expansion a
new partnership a new stuff pack but
we're not done yet phone oh no we're not
Mike Enzi brought one more big surprise
for all of you guys yes I know you're
all hoping so we thought maybe we could
tell you which game pack we had in mind
oh I don't know I I think maybe we could
conjure up something all right Mike I'll
let you spell it out for them the next
game pack for the sims 4 is realm of
magic that's amazing
I mean why don't we get more info on
this I mean aside from the fact that
you've just told us just now and like
you had just told us this yes so we will
tell you more about the game pack later
this year so you'll have to wait a
little more but it is coming this fall
it is coming this fall yes wow I can't
wait these guys clearly can't wait
community members asking a little bit so
big thank you to Lindsay and Michael and
thank you so much for showing us what's
next to the sims 4 so let's just quickly
recap this because there's a few things
to get through and it's hot and you
might have forgotten so the island
living reveal trailer is live now the
expansion is playable here at EA play
and you can play it at home soon but it
gets better fried content starts rolling
out and in a few weeks
oh sorry in a few weeks and the rest you
know stuff that comes out later this
summer so don't forget to check out all
the sims social channels for even more
info and launch dates so that's it for
the sims it's been an exciting day here
with so so much news I can't wait to
join the fan fest and get my hands on
the island living expansion packs so
from all of us here goodbye we'll see
you later
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all for watching EA play 2019
we hope you enjoyed all these exciting
reveals skate for I'm sorry we just ran
out of time
I'm Greg Miller and I'd say I had a lot
of fun hosting this show but that of
course would have been a lie this has
been the worst I've been yards from all
these great games have been able to go
play any of them now it's my time if
you're in Los Angeles come out and see
everything we've got for you in person
if you're not in Los Angeles or you're
just lazy like me don't worry because
these games will be in your hands before
you know it this has been EA play 2019
I'm done playing go play
all right great let's get going where's
my Sherpa where's snow bike Mike Mike
Mike come on what are we gonna see what
do we got to see we're gonna see yeah
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone we're not on the wide mic
yet but I'm like my heart there we go
we're here the first official day for us
at least of III 2019 it's that time of
year like I said I'm Mike McCarty
I'm here with Lucy James know Michael hi
I'm Heidi and Kelly plaguey yeah we will
be here for the next few days doing pre
and post shows for the vast majority of
the press conferences tomorrow we'll be
Microsoft Bethesda obviously Sony is not
here this year but Ubisoft and square
will be wrapping stuff up Monday and
then we'll be getting to all the
appointments and demos and our stage
show will be here for the next six days
you're stuck with us deal with it yeah
we just saw EA play which is kind of a
new format for them they went half hour
with six of their big games kind of one
game that was maybe a few months ago we
wouldn't expect to be missing we'll get
to that but let's just jump right into
it first off we finally saw like you
know gameplay of Jedi fallen order Vince
Zampella went on stage to show it off
third person action game Michael would
you take on it so far
oh it's Star Wars Dark Souls that's
right I said it I got out of the way
it's Dark Souls Sykes is like growling
but what surprised me was that because I
was thinking of Jedi Knight Jedi Outcast
Jedi Academy like those games from Maxim
de force unleash maybe I was like oh
they might the channel some of that
energy and they are but I think that you
know for respond to kind of build this
game that's a lot more it's a little bit
slower and more deliberate than those
past games and they're going with that
that heavy style of combat that's a
little bit more they keep saying
thoughtful and uh yeah and yeah yeah I
get it too and yeah I really want to
play a Star Wars game in that vein so
I'm surprised by the direction they're
going with the combat and there's like
some uncharted exploration elements also
I think I haven't been able to read the
Game Informer cover story but they also
talked about like Metroidvania elements
when it comes to the exploration yeah
apparently they were saying there's not
gonna be many waypoints they're gonna
try to despite it's not obviously not
open world but they do want you to do
exploring on your own and so far as like
maybe it is that Metroidvania aspect but
right here you see him which
force pull the vine and then swing on it
they obviously the force attacks and
defensive maneuvers are a big part it's
pretty spoon slow so actually I want to
get to that about the respawn thing
because if I like say I just came to
this didn't know who was making it and I
saw this in a vacuum I don't know that I
would just immediately say Oh respawn
yeah we cool like I like that this is a
this is like even like apex legends it
was a new direction for them in a sense
but that clearly had titanfall DNA this
just seems like a brand new thing
they're doing yeah you get like bits and
pieces like with the wall running but
yeah you don't really put your finger on
it right away I do I want to go back
really quickly